Das Knistern im Hintergrund deutet es an. Dieses selbst erklärende Stück Kraftwerk deutet hin auf das Chaos Radio, das jetzt für drei Stunden ansteht. Mit einem ganz speziellen Thema, das ich mir so gar nicht merken konnte, aber ich bin ja auch nur stiller Beobachter. Im Studio vor allem vom Chaos Computer Club Mitch, Andreas und Tim, guten Abend.
Hallo, guten Abend. Ja, wir lassen uns hier noch ein bisschen mehr knistern. All die schönen Gewinde, die du hier heute einsacken kannst.
Ja, das find ich auch sehr lieb von euch. Ja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist wirklich formidabel. Man hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass Hacker auch so spendabel sein können, aber es gibt tatsächlich ein Spiel, das auf diese Art gemenzt worden ist, gemenzt. Und zwar nennt es sich Buzzword Bingo, und zwar mit Hackerbegriffen operierend, wenn wir da konform gehen, richtig?
Genau, also in unserem Fall, man kann das natürlich auch mit allen anderen Buzzwords spielen. Es gibt da ja eine ganze Menge zur Auswahl.
Genau, also die Erfindung kommt ganz offensichtlich aus Dilbert, wo das ein beliebter Zeitvertreib in langweiligen Meetings ist. Und naja, die Regeln sind eigentlich ganz einfach. Man macht sich eine recht eckige Tabelle, wie man das von Bingo halt so kennt, mit Begriffen drin. Jedes Mal wenn ein Begriff fällt, darf man den ankreuzen, wenn man eine Zeile oder eine Spalte oder eine Diagonale fertig hat. Dann schreibt man Bingo und dann gewinnt man.
Ja, ich hab mir dafür extra hier so ein Geräusch vorbereitet und ich hab mir tatsächlich auch schon zwei neuen Feldergeschichten vorbereitet. Ich hoffe, dass da überhaupt irgendwas von fällt, weil man ja nie weiß.
Ich dachte, man muss Bingo rufen.
Eigentlich muss man Bingo rufen, ja.
Bingo muss man nur das machen.
Du darfst aber auf den Buzzer drücken, wenn du dir ein Kreuzchen machst. Und wir ignorieren das dann einfach und reden weiter.
Genau. Wir wissen irgendwie frühestens nach dem dritten äh könnte es ein Bingo geben.
Ihr habt noch nichts erwähnt. Ich habe noch keine Kreuzchen machen können, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Okay, es gibt ja auch tolle Preise zu gewinnen.
Ja zum Beispiel. Was ist denn da, was erwartet nicht da?
Es geht erstmal so los mit so ein bisschen Schoko-Pralinen. Knistert auch schön, ist sehr radio-kompatibel. Und danach gibt es irgendwie noch mehr Schokolade. Also beim zweiten Bingo gibt es hier schon so eine Schokoladen-Coup.
Sieht sehr geil aus.
Sehr reizvoll.
Muss ich jetzt mal sagen für all diejenigen, die es nicht sehen können.
In dezentem Plastik irgendwie eingehüllt, also sehr modern. Und als Hauptpreis heute Abend bei Dreimal Bingo. Hier gibt es einen CCC Energy Drink. Inklusive, also es ist ein Komplettangebot, steht hier auch noch mal drauf, inklusive Kondomen. Das haben wir von der Tagesstelle gefunden.
Das ist wirklich sehr schön.
So was findet man jetzt in der Tagesstelle.
Also zumindest mir wird es heute Abend gut gehen, wenn ich mich nicht zu doof anstelle in den nächsten drei Stunden. Und Tatsache ist ja, ihr wollt dann auch diese Begriffe, die ich mir hier notiert habe, bewerten. Es wird ja nicht einfach nur hingenommen, sondern nach jedem Brummen wird quasi gefragt, welches es war.
Das können wir auf jeden Fall machen.
Damit auch wirklich klar ist, ob es sich um genuine Hackerbegriffe handelt oder Dreck.
Super, wir können das auch noch anfassen.
Ja sicher, natürlich. Ja, aber das eigentliche Thema heute Abend, was wäre das denn? Wollt ihr das schon verraten?
Ja, ich glaube, das können wir schon verraten. Es geht heute um objektorientierte Programmierung.
Also sagen wir mal, es geht um Programmierung.
Im Allgemeinen.
Mit dem Schwerpunkt der objektorientierten Programmierung. Und was sich dahinter verbirgt, das kommt in die Wellen.
Mit gelegentlichen Ausflügen in die Psychologie der Wahrnehmung und ähnliches Exotisches.
Ja, wollen wir noch ein Stückchen Musik hören vorher?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Ja. Bis dann, tschüss.
Ich muss zugeben, dass ich das auch als von euch erfahren habe, weil ihr auf der Seite des Pultes sitzt, wo immer die ganzen Aufkleber angebracht werden, wenn Bands da sind, wo Leute was hinkritzeln, Grüße hinterlassen und ähnliches. Und Oralapostel finde ich schon, sage ich mal finde ich, würde mir aber nach dem dritten Mal voll auf den Sack gehen. Als Name, also es ist zu deutlich. Es ist nicht filigran genug. Da fehlt mir was.
Zu explizit.
Ja, zu explizit. Durchaus.
Das sieht ja total schlecht aus.
Man merkt schon das Chaosradio, das sich natürlich mit allen Dingen beschäftigt und außerdem heute abendlich ein Thema auch noch andere Sachen mitgebracht haben, dürften nämlich Neuigkeiten in Sachen Chaos Radio und Chaos Computer Club. Ihr hattet Kongress sogar noch zu D-Mark-Zeiten, nicht? Das ist ja historisch fett formuliert, noch zu D-Mark-Zeiten. Also vor Neujahr hatte Chaos Computer Club Kongress. Und wir hatten gerade, das ist natürlich jetzt Insiderwissen, aber wir hatten gerade kurz darüber gesprochen, da fiel erst die Bemerkung, Gott, da können wir ja gar nichts erzählen, bis auf die Sachen, die wir nicht erzählen dürfen. Und da bin ich natürlich gespannt, nicht?
Na ja, das erzählen wir dir jetzt nicht. Also es ist da halt so, wir haben da auch ein Netz, wo man seinen Rechner mitbringen kann und den da hinstellen kann mit einer dicken Internetleitung, damit man auch mal größere Downloads von Linux FTP-Servern oder was weiß ich machen kann. Und es gibt da auch gelegentlich Leute, die sozusagen die netz-Infrastrukturen benutzen, nicht wissen, dass natürlich sowohl andere Leute, die da sitzen, das mitsniffen, als auch die, die am anderen Ende der Internetverbindung hängen und dann Dinge tun, die sie eigentlich nicht tun sollten. Und naja, es kam dazu kleineren Zwischenfällen und so ein Glückes.
Wenn ich zusammenfassen darf, es ist etwas dramatisch.
Nein, es ist überhaupt nichts passiert. Es ist halt nur immer wieder bemerkenswert zu sehen, wie wenig die Leute verinnerlicht haben, was es bedeutet, mit dem Internet zu arbeiten. Und zwar insbesondere auf so einer Hackerveranstaltung. Ich meine, wenn man bei sich irgendwie im Büro sitzt, wo noch drei andere Leute, die nie einen Computer haben wollten, irgendwie lustlos in ihr Word rein hacken, dann kann ich sicherlich meine E-Mail auch irgendwie sagen wir mal ein bisschen unverschlüsselt ziehen oder mich irgendwo mal unverschlüsselt einloggen, sofern ich den dahinter liegenden Internet Service Providern vertraue, was man auch nicht tun sollte. Aber gerade auf so einer Hackerveranstaltung ist also jedes im Klartext. Wo ist eigentlich die Musik? Hab ich die ausgeschaltet oder hast du die nicht eingeblendet?
Um Ruhe zu haben, um das genießen zu können.
Ich finde das so besser.
Viel angenehmer natürlich. Naja, jedenfalls gab es da Leute, die haben ihre Mails unverschlüsselt abgerufen und sich unverschlüsselt auf Rechner eingeloggt und da gab es eine große Leinwand und ein Beamer, wo dann die Passwörter jeweils für wenige Sekunden, nämlich bis der nächste sich unverschlüsselt eingeloggt hat, angezeigt wurden. Man konnte da daneben stehen und sich darüber freuen.
Aber das sind jetzt nicht wirklich normal Menschen gekommen, nur um ihre E-Mail abzurufen, oder?
Nö, das nicht, aber eigentlich Leute, die es besser wissen, sollten nämlich Leute, die an unseren Kongressen teilnehmen. Aber auch da scheint die Paranoia noch nicht ausreichend ausgebreitet zu sein, so dass Leute das immer wieder tun.
Ansonsten war es wieder ein lustiger Kongress, wer da noch nicht war, ich hab dich gerne eingeladen, mal vorbeizuschauen.
Also worum es eigentlich geht, ist natürlich nicht das Netz, sondern die Vorträge, die da stattfinden und die Leute, die da hinkommen, Weiterbildung, Knüpfung von Kontakten und so weiter und so fort. Und wir machen das auch schon eine Weile. Die Veranstaltung war glaube ich 1984 das erste Mal, die 18. hatten wir.
Genau.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob man bei so einer Veranstaltung nach Highlights fragen kann, aber wer hat denn den coolsten Vortrag gehalten?
Das ist schon entschieden.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, da kann auch keiner abschließend sich ein Urteil darüber wöhnen, einfach weil es so viele Vorträge gab. Also noch mehr. Immer drei bis vier gleichzeitig und keiner war überall. Aber es gibt Mitschnitte. Wir haben auf unserem FTP-Server die Audio-Mitschnitte der Kongresse, der Vorträge. Und vielleicht demnächst. Die FU Berlin hat gemeint, sie würde uns bandbreit sponsoren, gibt es auch Videomitschnitte der Vorträge. Das heißt, selbst wer da nicht war, kann sich das angucken.
Dann munkelt man bzw. ihr habt es mir gerade kurz angedeutet, dass Blinkenlight, die Installation auf dem Alex, sich bald verabschieden wird. Ist das richtig?
Das ist richtig. Es ist bald Schluss.
Wann?
Also der Termin ist jetzt noch nicht 100%ig, aber wahrscheinlich werden wir am 23. unserer Abschlussparty machen. Und am 24. also in der Nacht auf den 24. Februar ist dann Schluss mit Geblinke. Ja, weil ganz einfach am 1. März die Sanierungsarbeiten beginnen und dann rücken sie mit schweren Geräten an und wollen das Ding irgendwie auseinandernehmen und dann müssen wir natürlich unsere Lampen und Computer rechtzeitig noch irgendwie in Sicherheit bringen. Und dann lief es auch viel, viel, viel länger, als wir uns jemals erhofft haben, dass es laufen würde. Wir sind ja mal von einer Woche ausgegangen. Jetzt sind es irgendwie schon fast fünf Monate oder so. Und das war eine schöne Zeit, aber es wird sicherlich auch, naja.
Also für alle, die es noch nicht kennen und jetzt sich gar nichts unter vorstellen können, Blinkenlights ist eine große Installation im Haus des Deras am Alexanderplatz, in der sich computerisierterweise viele Lämpchen eingefunden haben, die lustige Sachen vollführen und immer noch auch mit Handy steuerbar oder gibt es das nicht mehr?
Genau, man kann mit dem Handy Pong spielen und man kann mit einer Software, die man sich unter blinkenlights.de herunterladen kann, eigene Filme machen für das Haus in 18x18 monochromen Pixel und das tun auch nach wie vor viele Leute, insbesondere weil sie sich irgendwie ihren eigenen Liebesbrief zusammen basteln möchten. Das ist ja so ein Extra-Dienst, den wir dann noch eingerichtet haben, dass die Leute irgendwie ihre Filme bauen können, irgendwie für eine Person oder wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall was Privates und der wird halt nur hinterlegt und wenn man dann das Pong angerufen hat, kann man noch seine Freischaltnummer hinterher schmeißen und dann läuft halt dieser Film, das man wieder auflegt und das wird irgendwie hervorragend angenommen, wie überhaupt die gesamte Installation hervorragend angenommen wurde. Wir haben irgendwie auf der BlinkenLights Webseite so zwischen drei und 15.000 Seitenabrufe pro Tag. Es sind irgendwie schon fast 1000 Filme eingegangen, allein einen guten Viertel davon sind diese Liebesbriefe. Ja und jetzt muss das halt alles irgendwie langsam sein Ende finden. Wir haben auch diesen Wettbewerb gestartet, also der beste Film kriegt noch einen Preis und das kriegt er nächste Woche auf der Transmediale, auf diesem Media Art Festival, was in Berlin stattfindet, im Haus der Kulturen Welt. Der Welt, da gibt es dann auch noch mal einen kurzen Vortrag zum BlinkenLights. Naja und dann ist halt bald Schluss. Und die letzten interessanten Informationen zum Projekt findet ihr auf der Homepage.
www.blinkenlights.de oder ccc.de?
BlinkenLights.de, aber wenn ihr irgendwie nicht wisst, wie man das schreibt, dann kommt ihr auch über www.ccc.de dahin.
Okay, dann geben wir uns noch einen Momentchen Pause und dann starten wir, würde ich sagen, mit dem eigentlichen Thema, nämlich Programmieren von vorne bis hinten.
Programmieren. Genau.
Programmieren, objektorientierterweise das Thema heute Abend für das Chaosradio und um mal einen verträglichen Einstieg zu garantieren, steht am Anfang die Frage, was ist eigentlich die Motivation zu programmieren auf eurer Liste obendrauf, richtig?
Richtig, auf der Liste, naja. Ich denke, um, sagen wir mal, verstehen zu können, worüber wir eigentlich reden wollen, dann müssen wir zumindest zu Beginn mal ein bisschen ausholen und erstmal ein paar andere Aspekte beleuchten. Und zwar vor allem, wie man überhaupt dazu kommt, in seinem Leben darüber nachzudenken, objektorientiert zu programmieren, weil da muss man zumindest schon mal auf die Idee gekommen sein, überhaupt zu programmieren. Und auch aus unserer Erfahrung heraus finden sich immer wieder viele Leute, die mit diesem permanenten in den Bildschirmen gestarren, überhaupt nichts anfangen können, die Leute für irgendwie etwas debil oder sonst wie benachteiligt halten. Und nicht so genau einschätzen können, was eigentlich, was die da eigentlich treibt. Aber ganz offensichtlich treibt sie ja etwas. Was treibt dich denn so, Andreas?
Tja, das ist relativ schwer zu beschreiben. Also vielleicht kann man mal anfangen, wie man anguckt, wie das denn losging. Also ich hab mich relativ früh schon für Mathematik interessiert und fand das alles hochspannend. Und irgendwann hat mein Papi, der auch schon damals dieses Kubernetes studiert hat, von Computern erzählt, ja, da sind diese Rechenmaschinen, aber das ist besser als eine Rechenmaschine, da kann man nicht sagen, was sie tun sollen. Und hat mich dann also irgendwann mit Computern beschäftigt, im zarten Alter von 12 Jahren. Und dabei geblieben bin ich eigentlich wegen der Faszination, die es hat, dem Computer komplexe Dinge tun zu lassen, die man sich vorher ausgedacht hat. Also viele Denkleistungen, die vorher da waren, waren relativ mechanisch. Also viele Leute kennen das aus der Mathematik in der Schule. Da ist man halt 80 Prozent der Zeit damit beschäftigt, irgendwelche Regeln, die man mal auswendig gelernt hat, anzuwenden, um ein Stückchen Formel von einem Format in ein anderes Format zu überführen, umzustellen und so weiter und so fort. Und es ist wenig eigentliche Denkleistung dabei, eigentliche Mathematik. Und der Computer nimmt einem die wiederholbare Arbeit halt ab. Man muss nur einmal drauf kommen, dass eine bestimmte Sache so und so gemacht werden muss. Und dann schreibt man das hin. Und ab sofort macht der Computer das automatisch. Und dann muss ich damit nicht mehr beschäftigen. Das ist also etwas, was auch der akuten Faulheit in den Menschen sehr entgegenkommt, weil die Neugier herauszufinden, wie man etwas tut, ist glaube ich das, was Leute, die programmiert, vereint. Und die Faulheit, nachdem man es herausgefunden hat, ist dann tatsächlich auch immer wieder zu tun, weil stattdessen könnte man ja herausfinden, wie irgendwas anderes funktioniert. Programmierst du, Max?
Naja, also nicht wirklich. Man hat mal diese Anfänge gehabt. Ich bin damals Feuer und Flamme gewesen. Das war so die Zeit, als ich hinter dem Weihnachtsbaum, als ich, wie alt war ich? Zehn, ohne kurz mit der Wimper zucken zu müssen, obwohl es sich in zehn Metern Entfernung befand, erkannt habe, dass dein Computer steht, den ich zu Weihnachten beschenkt bekomme, und zwar ein Commodore 128 sogar. Also damals der Ferrari, weil alle anderen hatten einen 64er, und es war natürlich ein schweineteures Ding, was absolut schwachsinnig war. Und da weiß ich, da habe ich immer, glaube ich, Turbo...
Was hat der da bezahlt?
Oh, ich glaube, wir haben damals 3000 Mark dafür bezahlt. Schon für einen 128er.
Auch weil der so teuer?
Ja. 3000?
Ja, also nicht die Version mit Computer in der Tastatur, sondern mit extra, so wie ein Desktop-Computer sah er noch aus.
Du redest von einem SX64?
Nein. Ich kann mich an dieses Modell erinnern, es gab plötzlich so monatlich davon.
Stimmt, den gab es auch noch als Desktop-Variante. Ach so, das war der erste, oder wie? Oder danach?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Also es war ganz neu auf dem Markt, das Modell, und vielleicht hat mein Vater mich auch angeschissen und wollte eher feuchten in mir erwecken, dass ich auch bloß was damit mache, dass es so teuer war, aber auf jeden Fall war es nicht billig. Das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Und dann habe ich so Grafik-Scheiß programmiert, weil ich immer eher ein visueller Typ war, und dieses ganze Zu-Lange-am-Code-Hängen ging mir auf den Sack, und darum wollte ich irgendwas haben, dann habe ich so Dinge gemacht, so, ja, so dass sich so ein Fahrrad selber zeichnet, irgendwie mit Circle so und Circle so, und also so eigentlich total dummes Zeug, außer dass am Ende ein Fahrrad da war, und da konnte ich meinen Vater so mit beeindrucken, dass er durchaus zufrieden war, mir Dinge gekauft zu haben. Und ansonsten... Oh Mann, ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Simon's Basic oder was?
Weiß ich nicht mehr. Das weiß ich nicht.
Da ist doch so ein Basic eingebaut.
Ja, aber der hatte keinen Circle, zumindest nicht das C64 Basic. Also nicht das Standard Basic von Commodore, hatte das nicht. Bin mir aber nicht so sicher, ob sie später noch mal eins nachgerüstet haben.
Wie hieß denn nochmal diese... gibt's Logo, kann das sein? Ich glaub, das hab ich irgendwann mal gemacht in der Schule.
Die Turtle-Grafik.
Genau, die Turtle-Grafik.
Immer schön, der kleine Schildkröte hinterher.
Ich glaub, das hab ich mal gemacht, und dann hab ich irgendwann mal ein bisschen versucht mit Java was zu programmieren und hab mir auch schön alle Befehls, Schnipel und Ketten immer in so ein Büchelchen geschrieben. Das Büchelchen hab ich heute noch nicht einmal reingeguckt. Das war so ein Muße-Ding. Das war so was, drei Wochen nichts zu tun, im Urlaub alle Bücher durchgelesen und dann ging's los. Rechner dabei, was kann man damit alles machen und bla, dann wurd's langsam interessant und mit Klassen und so und irgendwie was rausfinden. Und was mich aber immer genervt hat, also was mir tierisch auf den Sack gegangen ist, ist, dass es so in den meisten Büchern, die man da zu dem Thema findet, absolut ätzende Beispiele gab, die keine Sauge braucht hat. Also solche Teile, wo du da saßt und dachtest, ne, das schreib ich nicht ab, verstehst du? Es ist auf der CD sowieso mit drauf. Warum soll ich das deswegen jetzt abschreiben? Und es ging immer so was wie, wenn Roberta mit zwei Torten schmeißt und der mit vier, da bauen wir jetzt mal ein Programm für, dass wir wissen, was ist, wenn beide zusammen schmeißen.
Ja super!
Und nicht mal irgendwie Landebahnlogistik oder sowas?
Das haben sie nur in Afghanistan gehabt, Landebahnlogisten.
Da sind wir aber schon beim echt interessanten Punkt, weil das hängt meiner Meinung nach auch sehr von der Programmiersprache ab, weil davon auch wiederum sehr die Szene abhängt, die hinter dieser Programmiersprache steht. Und bei Java ist es halt recht breitbandig. Also kann durchaus sein, dass es sich unter anderem an Leute wendet, die halt irgendwie das Tortenproblem mit Roberta und so wirklich schon immer mal in den Griff kriegen wollen.
Wobei es schon multimedial orientiert sein soll, vor allen Dingen deswegen, weil es plattformübergreifend ist. Das heißt, man kann überall was damit anfangen. War die Motivation sehr hoch, dachte ich, okay, wenn ich dann was mache. Man kann auf Webseiten was damit machen, irgendwie mit JavaScript und so, was natürlich jetzt wieder was anderes ist, aber irgendwie war die Nähe dafür da und ich dachte, okay, toll. Und dann war es mir aber doch wieder alles zu doof. Und dann das Dumme ist, was ich finde, man muss konkret was haben, was man wirklich programmieren will. Wenn man das nicht hat, dann kann man es sich sparen. Also, weil wenn man keine Motivation hat, irgendwas hinzukriegen, wie eine bestimmte Datenverarbeitungsmethode oder eine Datenbank oder so, ist es für einen Arsch. Weil es fällt einem eh nichts ein, was man programmieren könnte. Ich meine, was habt ihr denn da das erste Mal gemacht?
Ich glaube, mein erstes Programm war ein Text-Adventure. Ein Text-Adventure? Das fing irgendwie so an. Ich hab immer gedacht, Computer sind was Cooles. Mit 8, 9, 10, kennt man aus Science-Fiction-Filmen. Die kann man Dinge tun lassen, das ist was ganz Fantastisches. Und dann irgendwann mal, als ich 14 oder 15 war, hab ich beim Freund, der hatte einen Computer, dann haben wir ein bisschen Computer gespielt und irgendwann sagt er, ich kann das Ding aber auch programmieren. Und zeigt mir also Teile und irgendwie kann ich mich an den Moment erinnern, wo mir klar wurde, dass mehr dahinter ist, als das, was man einfach auf dem Bildschirm sieht, sondern dass die Zeilen, die da oben raus scrollen, nicht etwa weg sind, sondern dass ein Speicher dahinter steht, den man manipulieren muss und eine Recheneinheit, die Anweisungen ausführt. Dann hab ich zu meiner Mutter gesagt, ich brauch so ein Ding möglichst bald. Ich akzeptiere nichts anderes und entstand halt irgendwann das Ding da und dann hab ich sofort angefangen zu programmieren.
Also Textadventure ist ja sehr geil, weil ich erinnere mich noch an Zork, was ich damals gespielt hab, was so mein Textadventure war, was ich sehr geliebt hab. Aber wie macht man so was? Weil es muss ja relativ intelligent sein, sodass es halt auch mehrere Sachen akzeptiert, weil nicht jeder den Befehl eingibt, den er sich vorgestellt hat, oder wie das Programm es sich vorgestellt hat, sagen wir mal so.
Es gibt nur fünf Befehle, die man... Nordwest, Süd, Ost und so. Das war das ganz einfache natürlich. Keine KI oder so.
Es ist halt nicht so, sondern es passiert exakt nur das, was man sich im Programm vorgestellt hat. Letztlich ist es halt der Programmierer, der irgendwie vorgibt, was passieren kann. Ich hab übrigens auch als erstes mir einen Textadventure irgendwie geschnappt und das irgendwie umgeschrieben.
Die gab's ja auch in Basic, also praktisch.
Ja, wo wir jetzt sowieso eine künstlerische Pause gesetzt haben, könnte man ja auch, weil es auch an der Zeit ist, grob Nachrichten passieren lassen. Und das machen wir auch jetzt.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
22.31, Info.
22.31, wollen wir es nochmal wiederholen. Das Wetter, nachts vereinzelt Regen, 8 bis 5 Grad. Morgen Durchzug eines Regengebietes. Nachfolgend Schauer bis 11 Grad. Wieder ziemlich windig. Und jetzt die Nachrichten mit Kerstin Dopp.
Der Bundestag hat am Abend der Einfuhr bereits existierender embryonaler Stammzellen unter strengen Auflagen zugestimmt. Damit scheiterten die Anträge für ein absolutes Importverbot sowie für eine weitgehende Freigabe der Einfuhr embryonaler Stammzellen. Deutschland soll wegen des erwarteten Haushaltsdefizits von 2, 7 Prozent einen sogenannten blauen Brief der EU-Kommission erhalten. Erlaubt sind höchstens 3 Prozent. Frankreich hat Vorschläge zur Überwindung der Nahostkrise unterbreitet. Dabei favorisiert Paris die Anerkennung eines Palästinenser Staates noch vor einer Aufnahme von Friedensverhandlungen. Der erste Gesamtdeutsche Kinder- und Jugendbericht ist heute von Bundesfamilienministerin Bergmann vorgelegt worden. Darin wird insbesondere für eine bessere, flächendeckende Kinderbetreuung plädiert. Brandenburg will mit einem neuen Arbeitsmarktmodell mehr Jobs für ausgebildete Jugendliche schaffen. Dabei sollen sich zwei Absolventen eine Stelle teilen. Das Arbeitsamt wird den Lohn jeweils auf 80 Prozent aufstocken. Und zum Sport im Viertelfinale um den DFB-Pokal gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Hertha BSC, 1. FC Köln 1 zu 2 nach Verlängerung. Bayer Leverkusen 1860 München 3 zu 0 und Schalke 04 Rot-Weiß Oberhausen 2 zu 0. Die Partie Kaiserslautern gegen Bayern München dauert noch an. Und in der Basketball-Euro League verlor der deutsche Meister Albert Berlin am Abend beim polnischen Titelträger Slask Breslau mit 66 zu 71. Die Verkehrsmeldungen A10, südlicher Berliner Ringen, Autobahn 3, Potsdam, Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz, zwischen Anschlussstelle Potsdam Süd und Autobahn 3, Drewitz, Nutetal Unfall, linker Fahrstreifen ist blockiert.
Danke Kerstin, 22.33 Uhr.
Abenteuer deines Lebens. Und du kannst hin. Fritz bringt dir das Abenteuer deines Lebens bis zum 2.
März.
Zur Eröffnung des Globetrotter Ausrüstungs-Negastore in Berlin-Steglitz. Und im Radio das Abenteuer deines Lebens.
Wir sind noch nicht durch.
Wir sind noch nicht ganz durch. Wir haben nämlich noch 2, 5 Stunden insgesamt vom Chaos Blue Moon heute Abend im Studio, meine Wenigkeit Herr Malodki und Mitch und Andreas und Tim.
Du hörst gar nichts. Hört ihr mich?
Wir hören dich klar und... Das ist normal. Guck mal.
Wir hören dich schon die ganze Zeit. Die Frage ist, hörst du dich?
Jetzt kann ich mich auch noch hören.
Wir haben die Technik im Griff.
Total.
Hat eine Weile gedauert.
Ich bin echt beeindruckt.
Das geht ohne Internet.
Wir waren gerade beim Programmieren bzw. den Anfängen und die Motivation, die dahinter steckt. Und vor allen Dingen, wie man anfängt. Und da scheinen ja bei euch, zumindest bei zwei Personen, Textrollenspiele.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es jetzt... Das Programm selber war vollkommen austauschbar. Jetzt muss ich erstmal mein blödes Handy ausschalten. Und dann schön mal leise machen. Also, das war nicht so wichtig, was man programmiert, denke ich. Also es war einfach wichtig, dass man programmiert.
Und vor allem, dass man anders konkret programmiert.
Das war auch so die Schlüsselerkenntnis war, dass man überhaupt erst mal verstanden hat, man kann diesen, oder man muss sogar dieser Maschine sagen, was sie zu tun hat. Und dann eben der Wunsch, herauszufinden, wie das geht. Und zwar möglichst genau.
Also ich denke, wir haben alle in einem Alter angefangen zu programmieren, als sowieso Spiel noch etwas völlig Normales war. Und irgendetwas zu programmieren, was eigentlich objektiv gar keinen Sinn machte, auch etwas völlig Normales war. Und das ist vor sich hin was, wie man in noch jüngeren Jahren die Lego-Steine zusammengesteckt hat. Hat man halt im Computer auch die Programmier-Lego-Steine zusammengesteckt. Und ich denke, das was fasziniert ist, ist das Potenzial, was dahinter steckt. So der Computer als Denkhammer, als Denkwerkzeug, dem man jedes beliebige Problem, auch wenn es eins ist, das man sich selber ausgedacht hat, näher bringen kann, um es zu lösen. Also auch im Gegensatz zum einfach nur irgendwelche Programme benutzen, weil da kann man sozusagen in der Regel nur den Denkmuster folgen, die jemand für einen vorgedacht hat. Es gibt nur eine begrenzte Anzahl Funktionen, die ist da halt eingebaut und dann klicke ich drauf und dann passiert das. Und wenn man etwas tun will, was noch nie jemand zuvor getan hat mit einem Computer, muss man zwangsläufig programmieren. Und interessant ist auch, dass das, was Programmierer mit Computern tun, für Leute, die nicht programmieren, immer auch so ein bisschen wie Magie aussieht. Und interessanterweise korreliert das auch mit einer Definition von Magie, die ich gefunden habe, von einem gewissen Alastair Crowley, bekannter Mathematiker, Bergsteiger und Schwarzmagier, mittlerweile aus dem vorvergangenen Jahrhundert.
Geliebt und gehasst und als Charlatan verschrien und auch als sehr weiser Mann.
Ja, ja, also blöd war er auf jeden Fall nicht, vielleicht ein bisschen sozial inkompatibel.
Auf jeden Fall ist er unspritzen, was schonmal nicht schlechtes sein kann.
Und der hat nämlich gesagt, Magic ist the science and art of causing change to occur in conformity with will. Also Magie ist die Wissenschaft und die Kunst, Veränderungen herbeizuführen in Übereinstimmung mit dem Willen. Und das, was ich da tue, ist, ich möchte etwas erreichen. Also am Anfang steht der Wille etwas zu tun. Und dann als nächste Stufe der Ausdruck des Willens in Sprache. Und in dem Fall halt nicht in menschlicher Sprache, sowie einen Zauberspruch, Abra Kadabra, auf zwei Beinen stehe, oben sei ein Kopf, eile nun und gehe mit dem Wassertopf, sondern in einer Programmiersprache, was ja eigentlich auch eine Form einer Sprache ist, aber eine Sprache, die gleichzeitig noch eine technische Funktion erfüllt, nämlich man kann sie auf einen Computer tun und ausführen.
Genau.
Und was sich halt daran auch anschließt sofort, ist die Überlegung, ok, jetzt habe ich begriffen, dass ich das tun möchte und ich habe vielleicht auch schon im Ansatz begriffen, wie ich es tun kann. Sagen wir mal, müssen die Grundzüge einer Programmiersprache irgendwie gerade näher gebracht worden durch Lesen oder Erklären von irgendjemand. Da hat man diesen Moment, wo man irgendwie vor der Maschine sitzt und sich denkt, ja und jetzt? Jetzt habe ich das Problem, was weiß ich, das Tortenproblem oder keine Ahnung, wie sortiere ich meine CDs so, dass ich immer das richtige Lied in dem Moment finde oder welche Aufgabe auch immer. Man sieht sich dabei einer grundlegenden ersten Fragestellung gegenübergestellt. Nämlich, wie ordne ich denn eigentlich jetzt alles an? Also was tut denn jetzt bitteschön womit, was auf welche Weise? Und der Vorgang, der dort eben dann ganz entscheidend ist, ist die Abstraktion. Man muss halt irgendwie in der Lage sein, seine Umgebung soweit zu verstehen und zu begreifen, dass man irgendwie abstrakte Modelle bauen kann. Damit man irgendwie innerhalb dieser Modelle mit den sich herausbildenden Rollen und Entitäten in irgendeiner Form was anstellen kann.
Ein Beispiel, kann man da ein Beispiel nennen?
Na klar, also ich meine, wenn du vom Tisch sitzt, also jetzt so auch im Real Life unabhängig von Computern, und die Abstraktion ist, was weiß ich, ich gucke hier auf den Tisch und sage hier stehen drei Flaschen Mate. Dann ist eigentlich in dieser kurzen Aussage schon eine ganze Menge zusammengefasst worden. Nämlich erstens, es gibt Mate. Das heißt, es gibt etwas, das man als Mate bezeichnet und was als Mate auch erkennbar ist. Und dann gibt es auch noch irgendwie Flaschen. Und dann gibt es auch noch genau drei davon. Das heißt, es ist auch schon klar abstrahiert, irgendwie Mate befindet sich in Flasche. Und Flasche kann irgendwie in einer zählbaren Größenordnung auftauchen. Das wäre jetzt nochmal der ganz einfache Ansatz heran. Und tatsächlich, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein Programm habe, was weiß ich, was zum Beispiel ein Getränkeautomaten steuert, ist ja eigentlich nicht so schwierig irgendwie. Da hat man so ein paar gelesen, wo man eine Flasche klackern lassen kann und man weiß dann halt einen Zähler irgendwie, wie viele Flaschen da drin sind. Dann arbeite ich halt auch genau damit. Das heißt, ich muss wissen, in dem einen Schacht ist Mathe, in dem anderen ist Cola, und am besten ist irgendwie Wasser. Und es wird irgendwie Geld reingeworfen. Und jetzt muss ich sozusagen den Bezahlvorgang irgendwie mitsummieren. Und wenn so und so viel Geld reingeworfen ist, dann darf man Taste XY drücken. Und schon eigentlich aus diesem, sich selber vorlesen, was eigentlich die Aufgabenstellung ist, gewinnt man relativ früh schon die Dinge, mit denen das Programm dann auch arbeiten sollte. Das heißt, es gibt Flaschen, es gibt Schächte, es gibt Schalter, es gibt Geldeinwurfschlitze, es gibt Geld, es gibt irgendwie Summen von Geld, es gibt irgendwie Grenzen, ab denen irgendwie etwas als bezahlt gilt, man muss Wechselgeld rausgeben und hat halt in irgendeiner Form in diesem Minicomputer, der in diesem Getränkeautomaten ist, alle Möglichkeiten von Tasten irgendwo drauf zu drücken. Und dann passiert das entsprechend in der realen Welt. Und richtig angenehm wird es dann, wenn man dann auch noch in der Lage ist, auf eine Art und Weise zu programmieren, die es einem ermöglicht, dieses abstrakte Modell, was man sich gerade so erarbeitet hat, auch vergleichsweise unmodifiziert und unverletzt direkt in die eigene Software mit zu übertragen. Und da wird es halt schwierig.
Also der entscheidende Punkt ist ja, dass Computer nicht das tun, was man will. Also es reicht nicht ihnen mitzuteilen, was man will, sondern man muss ihnen sagen, was sie tun sollen. Und diese Transformation aus dem Willen am Anfang und der Handlungsanweisung am Ende, das ist das, was den Programmierprozess ja ausmacht. Und nun sind Computer eigentlich relativ doof. Die können Zahlen addieren und multiplizieren, können sie an eine bestimmte Stelle in Speicher schreiben, können sie wieder aus dem Speicher auslesen. Und das war es auch schon fast. Also viel mehr macht so ein Computer einfach nicht. Und alles das, was an höheren Features drinsteckt, an intelligenterem, in Anführungszeichen, Verhalten, das sind bereits Abstraktionsebenen, die da jemand hin programmiert hat. Und eine der ersten Entwicklungen, also am Anfang wurden Computer tatsächlich so programmiert. Da war so ein Panel, da war ein lauter Schalter. Dann hat man sich sein Programm hingeschrieben als Nullen und Einsen auf dem Blatt Papier. Hat dann jeweils da an den Schalter Nullen und Einsen eingestellt. Dann hat man rechts auf den Bestätigungsknopf gedrückt. Dann wurde diese Instruktion übernommen in den Speicher. Und der Zeiger wurde ein zweiter gezählt. Man durfte dann die nächste Instruktion an den Schalter einstellen. Und solange bis man seinen Bootstrapcode eingegeben hat, mit dem das System dann also hoch lief, dann hat man auf den Knopf gedrückt, dann wurde das ausgeführt. Und weil das ja irgendwie kein Zustand ist und man da nicht vernünftig arbeiten kann, wurden dann also Techniken entwickelt, die Abstraktion ermöglichen. Die erste Abstraktion war die Einführung des Assemblers, dass man also nicht mehr Nullen und Einsen hingeschrieben hat, sondern sogenannte Memonics verwendet hat. Das heißt, Abkürzungen, die man sich merken kann, zum Multiplizieren statt 01100110010. Und daraus sind dann auch höhere Programmiersprachen entstanden, wo man dann also nicht mehr direkt sagt, schreib das nach Speicheradresse A, sondern wo man der Speicheradresse einem Namen geben kann, wo man komplexere Funktionen zusammenfassen kann, zu Unterroutinen, also auch das musste alles erst erfunden werden. Und ich denke, die Erfindung der objektorientierten Sprachen war da ein gewaltiger Schritt, weil das objektorientierte Programmieren der Art und Weise, wie wir Dinge in der wirklichen Welt klassifizieren und wie wir sie behandeln, sehr nahe kommt. Das objektorientierte Programmieren ist nichts, was der Computer als Technologie voraussetzt, sondern ist etwas, was dem Programmierer hilft, die Welt zu verstehen, um das Verhalten der Welt in Regeln ausdrücken zu können.
Ja, was immer noch relativ abstrakt ist. Also, als Leid bin ich noch nicht...
Das wird halt im Idealfall auch möglichst abstrakt bleiben. Aber du hast recht, was man, glaube ich, verstehen muss. Wenn es irgendwann nicht mehr abstrakt wird irgendwie, dann wird es echt zu konkret. Dann ist man wahrscheinlich gerade dabei, einem Fehler auf die Spur zu kommen, wo man sich mit so ganz widerlichen Dingen, mit welches Bit wird denn jetzt tatsächlich ganz tief unten in den Speicher reingeschrieben, sich mit so etwas auseinandersetzen muss, wo man das eigentlich gar nicht möchte. Aber das ist natürlich ein kerniges Thema, was wir uns ausgesucht haben. Aber wir halten das auch für wichtig, mal das darzustellen, was sozusagen da die Triebkräfte dahinter sind. Aber was, glaube ich, helfen kann, um das zu verstehen, was wir sozusagen jetzt mit dieser besonderen Form der Programmierung, Objektorientierung beschreiben möchten, ist, wie eigentlich jetzt ein Computer mit einem Programm umgeht. Hast du das eigentlich eben schon erwähnt mit der Trennung zwischen Code und Daten?
Nein, das hatte ich noch nicht erwähnt.
Ja, man muss wissen, wozu wir dieses Geräusch hier reserviert haben. Ich spiele Buzzword Bingo für Hacker. Was bedeutet, dass ich mir hier ein kleines Grid gemacht habe mit neuen Wörtern drin und es muss ein Bingo rauskommen, in dem ich mindestens drei Wörter, diagonal, horizontal oder vertikal, da quasi angestrichen habe. Und ich habe das erste Wort erreicht. Ja, ich sag's dir schon. Ich hab's nicht ganz. Also, ihr habt Code gesagt und ich hab aber Coden als Verb. Gilt das?
Oh, lass mal gelten.
Ich glaub nicht, dass du in der entscheidenden Phase so leicht davon kommst, aber...
Es ist auch noch ein langer Weg, bis du drei in einer Reihe hast.
Aber stimmt, das ist schon echt Slang.
Kohl ist echt ein...
Gibt's einen Bonus, ja? Dann mach ich mir hier noch eine kleine Ente oben links.
Ein Sternchenkrippe.
Erst mal eine Ente.
Ich wollte euch nicht unterbrechen.
Damit darfst du uns ja unterbrechen. Aber sonst nicht, ja?
Nee, natürlich nicht. Ich hab nur Bonbons hier. Also ich amüsiere mich mit Bonbons.
Ein bisschen.
Aber ihr wart an der Stelle, ich würde das gerne noch her. Ihr habt kurz erwähnt, wie das alles angefangen hat, mit Schalterchen und so. Und dann ging es aber direkt auf objektorientierte Programmierung. Was ist das überhaupt, bevor wir da wirklich einsteigen?
Ja, objektorientierte Programmierung ist eine... Also man kann da aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln rangehen. Wir haben bisher versucht zu erläutern, was so der programmierpsychologische Aspekt davon ist. Also wie nehme ich die Welt wahr? Und das hat natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch eine technische Ausprägung. Nämlich, wie sieht die Programmiersprache aus? Welche Features hat die Programmiersprache? Und so weiter und so fort. Und grob gesprochen ist Objektorientierung, dass man in seiner Software eine Einteilung von Dingen, eine Hierarchisierung von Dingen macht, genauso wie man sie in der normalen Welt macht. Das heißt irgendwie, ich habe vor mir eine Flasche Clubmate zu stehen. Das ist eine ganz konkrete Flasche Clubmate. Ich kann sie benennen, das ist die. Und jetzt gibt es aber auch noch andere Clubmate Flaschen. Das sind die und die und die und die. Und so eine Flasche Clubmate ist eine spezielle Variante eines Behältnisses mit einem flüssigen Nahrungsmittel drin. Das wiederum ist ein Objekt, das man durch die Gegend werfen kann, im Gegensatz zu einem abstrakten Gedanken, den man sich vorstellt. Und was alle Gegenstände mit flüssigen Nahrungsmitteln vereint, ist die Tatsache, dass man daraus trinken kann. Und wie konkret das Trinken jetzt funktioniert, hängt von der spezifischen Ausprägung der Flasche ab. Also im Falle ist es eine Flasche mit einem Schraubverschluss. Also kann ich da den Schraubverschluss öffnen. Und da merkt man schon, dass eine Hierarchisierung drin. Also es geht von konkretem Objekt zu Behältnis mit Getränk, zu Flasche mit Schraubverschluss mit Getränk drin, zu Flasche Clubmate, zu der konkreten Flaschen Clubmate, die ich jetzt vor mir habe und aus der ich jetzt ein Schlückchen trinke werde, wodurch sich ihr Zustand ändert.
Also der Knackpunkt an dem ganzen ist dieses Ist ein. Also eine Flasche mit Clubmate ist eine Flasche mit Flüssigkeit ist eine Flasche ist ein Ding, aus Glas ist ein Ding überhaupt. Also so wie ein Mensch ist ein Wirbeltier ist ein Lebewesen ist ein......Säugetier und so weiter.
Was die ganze Geschichte nützlich macht, ist das Objekte, die alle eine gewisse Ist ein Eigenschaft haben, ähnliche Operationen unterstützen. Also zum Beispiel Trinken. Ein flüssiges Nahrungsmittel zu sich nehmen ist Trinken. Und das Trinken aus Flaschen funktioniert für alle Flaschen gleich, ob das jetzt eine Flasche mit Clubmate oder eine Flasche mit Bier ist. Vielleicht abgesehen vom Öffnen, aber das ist dann wieder so ein Sonderfall, wo man einfach dann eine andere Mixing-Klasse erbt. Aber dazu kommen wir später.
Schon klar, eine Mixing-Klasse erben. Das will auch nicht auch passieren, damit wir uns was von kaufen können.
Um vielleicht nicht so viele Schritte auf einmal zu machen. Der Anfang... Also wenn ich programmiere, ich will noch mal einen Schritt zurückgehen, um das klarzumachen. Also die klassische Form des Programmierens, so wie du sie auch am Anfang am C64 gemacht hast, so Basic ist ein gutes Beispiel. Da werden halt zwei Dinge generell unterschieden. Das eine sind deine Daten. Also ein Text, der angezeigt wird. Eine Zahl, die ausgerechnet wird. Andere Konstanten, die da mit in die Formen hineinbezogen werden. Also dein gesamtes Modell, alles was in irgendeiner Form greifbar ist, herumliegt oder modifizierbar ist, aber dann diesen Zustand auch beibehält, das sind halt Daten. Und dein Programm, was du schreibst, das ist Code. Das ist das, was eben der Maschine sagt, was mit diesen Daten zu geschehen hat. Das ist tatsächlich die korrekte Beschreibung, wie ein Computer heutzutage funktioniert. Also das Modell von von Neumann, wie ein Computer funktioniert, basiert im Prinzip auf dieser Idee. Man hat halt Daten und man hat Code und man hat sie gemeinsam innerhalb einer Maschine und der Code kann mit den Daten irgendetwas tun. Das ist sozusagen das Yin und Yang des Computers.
Also interessant wird es da, wo die Grenzen überschritten werden. Also wenn man ein Programm schreibt, schreibt man ja eigentlich erstmal Daten hin, nämlich einen Fall mit Programmtext, aus dem dann Code wird. Und ähnlich, wenn man sich hinterher im Debugger das Programm anguckt, wird aus dem Code wieder Daten. Oder wenn man anfängt, selbstmodifizierenden Code zu schreiben, ähnliche Dinge, wenn man Bufferoverflows schreibt. Aber ich seh unser Süßkram schon schwimmen.
Es tut mir ja sehr leid, aber... Also es sind auch nicht so die klassischen Hackerwörter, aber Debuggen hab ich mir aufgeschrieben.
Großartig.
Nicht schlecht, wie ich das antizipiert habe.
Ich hatte mich schon gefragt, ob du das hast. Du müsstest vielleicht auch gleich mal erklären.
Ja, Debuggen.
Wenn du es aufgeschrieben hast, kannst du es ja sicherlich auch erklären.
Sicher, klar, das muss ich natürlich wissen. Ja, Debuggen. Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz täusche, ist es das, was ich in meiner Programmiersprache verfasst habe, in Maschinencode zu übersetzen, richtig?
Debuggen ist das Entwansen von Programmen, also das Fehler beseitigen.
Debuggen ist sozusagen der Fehler. Debuggen ist das Entfernen des Fehlers. Und Debuggen ist der Vorgang des Entfernens.
Was war denn das?
Das ist ein halber Punkt Abzug, wenn nur das Basswort aber nicht die Bedeutung gewusst.
Eigentlich gibt das bei Basisword Bing ein Zusatzpunkt.
Stimmt, aber nur das Basswort weiß die Bedeutung nicht. Das ist ein Zusatzpunkt.
Was fange ich denn mit den Zusatzpunkten an?
Da können wir ja nachher darüber diskutieren.
Also dann einen Zusatzpunkt habe ich jetzt noch. Aber wie nennt sich das denn, wenn man den... Da gibt es doch auch einen Code. Compiling macht man.
Ach du dickes Ei.
Bei mir war es Verpiling.
Compiler macht aus Datencode.
Das ist ein scheiß Spiel, bringt euch immer voll raus. Ich weiß nämlich auch nicht mit woher ihr es tut.
Das ist immer eine gute Bremse. Nicht weil, aber Code und Daten sind nichts, was man heutzutage nicht kennen würde. Ich erinnere mich noch gut vor einigen Jahren, also wie viele Jahre sind das? Drei oder vier Jahre vielleicht? Sind es schon fünf? Ich weiß es nicht. Haben sich Menschen an uns gewandt und gesagt, Chaos Computer Club, erklärt mir doch, kann ich über eine E-Mail einen Virus empfangen und kann er meinen Computer zerstören? Daraufhin ernten diese Leute lautes Gelächter. Weil wir natürlich klar gesehen haben, dass es nicht bei E-Mail um Daten handelt, die übertragen werden und nicht um Code. Wie soll ein Text auf einmal anfangen, den Computer zu übernehmen? Das geht einfach nicht. Aber das ist halt so die Nerd-Logik. Kannst du auch Nerd erklären?
Ich kann Nerd nie von Geek unterscheiden. Aber Nerds sind die Hardcoreigeren als die Geeks, sagen wir es mal so. Die Geeks sind eher so die konsumorientierten, ich möchte dieses Technikding gerne haben Typen, so wie ich mich so quasi sehe, wenn das richtig sein sollte. Und die Nerds sind so die, die nicht merken, dass sie einen Rückenschaden kriegen, weil sie sich schon 48 Stunden an der Konsole befinden sozusagen.
Also du bist überraschend konform mit dem langen Schaltwörterbuch, aber ich glaube bei uns herrscht der Konsens, dass es genau andersrum der Fall ist. Achso, klar. Nerd ist eigentlich so der, wie soll ich sagen, man ist schon ein Nerd, wenn man sich irgendwie nerdig verhält, und der Geek ist irgendwie der Nerd, der jetzt auch besondere technische Begeisterung in Perfektion versucht zu erreichen. Es gibt schon eine schöne Sache, den Geek-Code. Im Internet schnell unter Eingabe von Geek-Code in google.com.
Also Geek hab ich natürlich auch, das mach ich jetzt Rickenkreuzchen. Ich weiß schon, wie ich euch dazu bringe, meine Wörter zu sagen.
Aber du hast das vor uns gesagt, das geht natürlich nicht.
Ach toll, dann krieg ich halt keine Ente dafür, okay?
Genau, gibt's auf jeden Fall keine Ente für. Ich hab auch den Buzzer nicht gehört.
Ja, ich... hat sich leicht verzögert. Also die Geeks sind tatsächlich die Hardcoreigeren dann, ja?
Ja, Geek hat schon etwas damit zu tun, dass man ein bestimmtes technisches oder wissenschaftliches Fachgebiet hat, auf das man sich konzentriert.
Da gibt es halt auch diesen schönen Geek-Code, der sich irgendwie bei manchen Leuten eingebürgert hat. Die schicken das dann mit jeder E-Mail mit oder mindestens auf ihrer Homepage zu finden. Der Geek-Code ist so ein möglichst langer String von kryptischen Zeichen, den man dann halt mittels der Geek-Code-Homepage irgendwie dekodieren kann, wo dann exakt wiedergegeben ist, also halt sehr kryptisch kodiert, aber dann doch relativ exakt wiedergegeben wird, welche Programmiersprachen man kann, welchen Wizard-Level man dann etwa erreicht hat. Wizard-Level? Hattest du nicht auf deiner Liste?
Nee, hab ich nicht auf meiner Liste, das nächste Mal.
Ja, das ist auch so als Begriff nicht unbedingt so gängig.
Wizard-Level?
Also Wizard schon, aber nicht unbedingt in dem Zusammenhang. Wie auch immer. Also jetzt hast du das glaube ich mit den Geeks und den Nerds irgendwie gespeichert, oder?
Ja, grundsätzlich dann doch.
Geeks und Nerds, Code und Daten. Ja, um die kleine E-Mail-Geschichte noch zu Ende zu bringen. Heutzutage kriegen natürlich die Leute am laufenden Meter Viren über E-Mail in ihren Computer, was sie nicht ohne Fassungslosigkeit beobachtet haben. Es lag vor allem im Wesentlichen daran, dass die Firma Microsoft auf die tolle Idee gekommen ist, eben genau das zu tun, also Code irgendwie in E-Mails rein zu hängen. Das finden sie ja auch noch für ein Feature. Und dann am besten auch noch diesen Code gleich vollständig ungefragt auszuführen, was natürlich irgendwie jeglichen Missbrauch Tür und Tor öffnet. Von daher ist es sozusagen an der Stelle manchmal etwas schwierig mit dem Code und den Daten.
Jungs, jetzt mal ganz kurz. Code und Daten. Nur, damit ich das im Bild habe. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, es werden irgendwie zwei Sachen gefallen. Einerseits, dass ich es so mache, dass es hinterher der Computer versteht. Und andererseits so das Programm und so ein Datenblock. Also bei BASIC war das dann immer so, dass man ein cooles Programm hatte, was man schreiben konnte. Das hat auch voll Spaß gemacht. Das war so baumäßig angeordnet mit Eingerückt und bla, und Go to zurück und Go to 10 und 20. Und dann musste man aber noch so einen Block schreiben, der nur aus dummen Zahlen bestand. Das sind die Daten, ja?
Das sind die Daten sozusagen. Für deine Circles und deine Sprites, die Data.
Das waren eher so die langweiligen, also im Grunde die Blöcke, die das Programm frisst sozusagen, um damit arbeiten zu können.
Genau, zum Beispiel. Alles, womit das Programm arbeitet, das sind halt Daten. Alles, was das Programm nicht selber ist.
Und genau diese Unterscheidung findet man natürlich auch in den Programmiersprachen wieder. Es gibt da ein sehr berühmtes Buch von Niklaus Wirt, das heißt Algorithmen und Datenstrukturen. Also es geht im Programm irgendwie darum, seine Daten, die man hat, sinnvoll anzuordnen, zu sortieren und Funktionen zu schreiben, die dann irgendwas Interessantes mit den Daten machen. Und da kommt die Objektorientierung wieder ins Spiel. Nämlich muss man ja Daten erstmal sehr häufig auf einen Haufen werfen. Wenn man einen Kreis mal zu einem Kreis hat, eine Position auf dem Bildschirm, die hier oben unterteilt sich in X- und Y-Positionen, hat einen Radius und eine Farbe und ist gefüllt oder nicht. Und man war relativ schnell dabei, solche Sachen zusammenzufassen in Strukturen. Und Objektorientierung ist sozusagen die Idee, das hierarchisch anzuordnen, zu sagen, ok, ich habe halt Grafikobjekte, die haben eine X- und Y-Position, dann habe ich einen Kreis, und ein Kreis ist ein besonderer Fall eines Grafikobjektes. Und hat noch zusätzlich einen Radius und eine Farbe. Aber alles andere soll genauso funktionieren, wie mit allen anderen Objekten, die eine Position auf dem Bildschirm haben, also dass man sie anordnen kann. Und in der Sprache der objektorientierten Programmierung redet man davon, dass man den Kreis sozusagen ableitet von der generischen Klasse auf dem Bildschirm positionierbares Objekt.
Aber geben dann die Programme im Grunde schon alle Objekte vor? Also dass man weiß, wenn ich meinetwegen Kreis habe, Circle, dann ist ein Circle immer an einer Position x, y, erscheinendes mit einem bestimmten Radius versehenes Ding.
Das ist das, was du dir als Programmierer ausdenkst, als Ordnungsmerkmal um deine Welt zu strukturieren. Also leider ist es so, dass viele Bücher, die einem versprechen, das Programmieren beizubringen, einem nicht das Programmieren beibringen, sondern versuchen eine Programmiersprache beizubringen. Und die ganze Theorie, die dahinter liegt, von Abstraktionen, von Algorithmen und so weiter und so fort, wird selten vermittelt. Also man findet wenig gute Bücher darüber. Und genau das versucht, die Objektorientierung zu erleichtern, einfach aus dem Grund, dass Programme ja beliebig groß werden können und dann beliebig komplex werden können. Und das menschliche Gehirn ist leider in der Kapazität begrenzt. Man kann so an sieben Sachen gleichzeitig denken. Und alle Programmkonstruktionen, die dazu führen, dass man, wenn man eine bestimmte Stelle Code vor sich hatten, die editieren will, mehr als sieben Sachen gleichzeitig im Kopf zu behalten, das funktioniert dann einfach nicht mehr.
Ich dachte, es waren fünf.
Das hängt davon ab. Also sieben ist der Durchschnitt. Es gibt auch wohl Leute, da ist es mehr. Und es gibt auch Leute, da ist es ein bisschen weniger.
Aber in unseren Verschwörungstheorien, das ist immer...
Was passiert denn, wenn man gleichzeitig an sieben Sachen denkt?
Ja, das tust du die ganze Zeit, wenn du versuchst, komplexe Probleme zu lösen. Oder auch zum Beispiel bei Telefonnummern. Wenn du eine Telefonnummer wählst, ist das halt die sieben Ziffern, die du gleichzeitig im Kopf hast. Also sieben Dinge, die dein Gehirn sozusagen abstrakt sich vorstellen kann, liegen da in Registern rum. Und man kann darüber nachdenken. Und sobald es mehr werden, muss man irgendeinen Trick finden, um mehrere dieser Dinge, die man im Kopf halten will, zu einem zusammenzufassen. Genau das tut man halt über Abstraktion.
Macht man ja eigentlich auch im richtigen Leben. Irgendwann teilt man halt so die Welt in irgendwie Idioten, Spinner, Flugschwätzer irgendwie und dann in etwas mehr potente Personen, die einen so umgeben. Und man klassifiziert seine Umwelt.
Ja, das ist ja auch unvermeidlich. Ich kann ja nicht die Zigarettenschachtel hier als irgendwie eine Ansammlung ihrer Achtecken. Achtecken passen schon nicht in meinen Kopf rein. Deswegen schrumpft es zusammen aufgrund von Abstraktion zu einem Objekt Zigarettenschachtel. Das ist also genau ein Item. Und irgendwie ist in einem Item auch das Rauchen drin. Und das Rauchen kann ich nebenher machen. Das ist nicht mal ein Item. Ich kann rauchen und trotzdem sieben Items im Kopf haben. Das ist also eine Art von Abstraktion, die man sich in der Realität aufbaut, die komplexe Sachen zusammenfasst. Also trinken zum Beispiel. Ich mach mir keine Gedanken, dass da jetzt Mate drin ist oder dass es eine Flasche ist, welche ein Glasgefäß ist, welche ein Gefäß ist, sondern ich trinke einfach aus der Flasche. Und genauso macht man sich halt ein Programmieren der Abstraktion und benutzen die Abstraktion mit einem ganz einfachen Interface, zum Beispiel Flasche, trink mal oder lass dich mal trinken und kümmere mich nicht drum, was da jetzt genau an spezieller Flaschenausprägung dahinter steckt.
Dann würde man auch ziemlich bescheuert werden, wenn man sich das alles bewusst machen würde.
Allerdings.
Es gibt ja auch gewisse Drogen, die den Effekt haben, diese Abstraktion zu durchbrechen und man plötzlich die Flasche nicht mehr einfach nur als Flasche, sondern als das konkrete Objekt vor sich betrachtet, in dem sich Flüssigkeit befindet, wo sich das Licht draufspiegelt und Bläschen aufsteigen. Und ein tolles Etikett ist auch dran und die Farbe.
Dann hast du eine Stunde was damit zu tun.
Dann hast du eine Stunde mit der Flasche zu tun. Das ist mal ganz spannend, aber das macht einem auch genau klar, wozu diese Features des Gehirns, diese Programmierbarkeit, diese Abstraktion, dieses Wegfiltern von Informationen gut ist. Wenn es einen bewusstseinserweiterten Effekt von Drogen gibt, dann der, dass man, wenn man eine bestimmte Droge konsumiert, bestimmte Gehirnteile einfach aufhören zu funktionieren, wenn man mit seiner Umwelt nicht mehr klarkommt.
Man möchte es nicht glauben, es geht grundsätzlich um objektorientierte Programmierungen im Blue Moon. Kommt man denn mit gewissen Drogen weiter im Programmieren? Das wäre ja mal eine Frage, die da dranhängt.
Es gibt Codeteile im FreeBSD-Code, die unter dem Einfluss von Pilzen entstanden sind.
Dann hätten wir das ja auch geklärt.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass da Codeteile irgendwie drin sind, weil sie unter dem Einfluss von so ziemlich jeder Du Ich kenne auch einige Projektin.
Windows ist ja komplett so entstanden wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube eher, dass es mit dem Einfluss von Cola entstanden ist und komischen fetten Burger.
Cola und Chips und fette Burger, ganz genau so. Aber wir wollen ja auch die Leute nicht da draußen spielen. Jetzt spielen wir erstmal ein ganz besonderes Lied, nämlich irgendwie ein romantisches Lied. Und wir grüßen damit auch jemanden, nämlich dieses Lied ist für Janka und für Nadja.
Mit dem Chaosradio. Komplette Stunde haben wir jetzt schon mal versucht zum Reißen, worauf wir im Endeffekt hinaus wollen, nämlich objektorientiertes Programmieren am heutigen Abend mit Mitch, Andreas und Tim und Malodkian Mikrofon und wir wollten nochmal, bevor wir jetzt endgültig zum Talk aufrufen, nochmal kurz umreißen, bis wo wir bislang gekommen sind, oder?
Meinst du zusammenfassen?
Ja, dachte ich.
Ja, wir hoffen halbwegs verständlich näher gebracht zu haben, dass es notwendig ist, dieser Welt eine gewisse Abstraktion entgegenzubringen, um sie zu verstehen und sie vor allem zu verarbeiten. Wenn man das mit einem Computer tun will, sollte man sich klar sein darüber, dass es da verschiedenste Möglichkeiten der Herangehensweise gibt. Programmieren als die eigentliche Wesensform, wie man einen Computer benutzen möchte. Zumindest uns geht es halt so. Wir benutzen den Computer natürlich auch für andere Dinge, aber sehr häufig eben auch einfach nur mit der Motivation programmieren, weil ich erschaffe mir halt gerne mal eine Welt oder löse auch ein konkretes Problem, was ich habe. Und das Objektorientierte Programmieren ist eben eine immer populärer werdende Form, wo es viele Gründe für gibt, warum man das eben so tun sollte. Das ist wirklich ein erkennbarer Trend, es wird immer mehr Objektorientiert auf allen Ebenen.
Vielleicht sollte man auch noch ein paar Begriffe klären, bevor wir jetzt in die tiefere Diskussion einsteigen.
Das können wir durchaus tun. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wir haben vorhin kurz darüber gesprochen, über diverse Bücher, die einem das Programmieren beibringen, beziehungsweise nicht beibringen, sondern nur die Programmiersprache. Die Kritiker hatten wir ja schon kurz. Und da steht ja auch immer was drin, zur Objektorientierten Programmiersprache. Und vielleicht könnte man, wenn ihr jetzt Lust habt, unter 03.73.97.1.1.0 auch einfach mal vortragen, was da bei euch zu Objektorientierter Programmiersprache stand, wie war das definiert, was ist das, arbeitet ihr viel damit, macht ihr da was mit, löst ihr da Probleme mit oder eben auch nicht. Aber es sollte sich wie gesagt nicht um eine reine Programmiersprache handeln, so einfach so, sondern eben halt um Objektorientiertes Programmieren.
Ob das nochmal eine Streitfrage für sich ist, ob eine Programmiersprache wirklich objektorientiert ist oder nicht.
Ja 03.3.1.70.97.1.1.0, könnt ihr euch mit einschalten, auch die dümmsten Fragen stellen, beziehungsweise nicht die dümmsten, weil die dümmsten stelle ich hier immer noch ich. So. Und da haben wir auch schon jemanden am Telefon, der sich natürlich sofort nach draußen an unsere Rezeption verzogen hat. Da müssen wir noch ein Momentchen warten. Du wolltest aber noch ein paar Begriffe klären, Andreas.
Ein paar Begriffe, ja. Wir haben ja schon von Objekten geredet. Objekte teilen sich weiter auf in Klassen und Instanzen. Und zwar meint Klasse sozusagen die generische Abstraktion und Instanz ein konkretes Objekt der Abstraktion. Das heißt, zum Beispiel bei Clubmate-Flaschen habe ich irgendwie Clubmate-Flasche, das wäre meine Klasse. Und diese Clubmate-Flasche hier vor mir, das ist die Instanz der Klasse.
Oder anders ausgedrückt, eine Klasse ist halt eine Wesensart von einem Objekt. Es gibt viele Objekte und sie haben halt, wie ich schon so meinte, is-e. Also das Objekt ist eine Flasche. Und dann gibt es halt eine Klasse, die heißt Flasche. Und in dieser Klasse sind die generellen Eigenschaften einer Flasche in irgendeiner Form gespeichert, wie man die dann auch immer dargestellt sehen möchte. Zum Beispiel die Flasche hat eine Inhaltsmenge. Sie hat auch, generell sagt sie schon mal, dass ein Objekt vom Typ Flasche auch einen Füllstand hat. Ist sie leer oder ist sie voll, ist sie geschlossen, ist sie geöffnet, vielleicht sieht sie nur aus, als wäre sie geschlossen, obwohl sie eigentlich schon freigeschraubt ist. All diese Dinge versucht man dann halt möglichst allgemein zu sammeln in dieser Klasse, die nur ein Modell ist, für dann eine konkrete Flasche, die man im Programm auch wirklich benutzt.
Also bei der konkreten Flasche sind dann auch die tatsächlichen Informationen gespeichert. Die Klasse weiß, es gibt einen Füllstand und die Instanz hier vor mir hat halt den konkreten Füllstand, ist eigentlich noch fast voll, weil habe ich ja gerade erst angefangen zu trinken.
Mal gucken, ob es dem Markus auch um Flaschen geht. Hallo.
Ich habe eine Frage. Ich bin angehender Administrator und wollte wissen, ob XML einfach beziehungsweise für einen Amateur einfach zu lernen ist.
Die Antwort lautet ja.
Das ist die Rettung der Welt.
Genau. XML ist nebenbei die Rettung der Welt und ist eigentlich sehr einfach zu verstehen. Es gibt da allerdings eine ganze Menge Protokolle und weitere Formate rund um XML bzw. die alle auf XML aufbauen, wie man sich da mit der Zeit auch näher bringen möchte. Aber XML ist auf jeden Fall nicht wirklich schwierig.
Also ich bin grundsätzlich unbedarft in der Programmierung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich kenn mich zwar mit Netzwerken und Microsoft-Produkten aus, aber interessiere mich halt jetzt für das XML bzw.
auch für die objektorientierte Programmierung.
Wobei das muss man vielleicht noch klarstellen. XML ist keine objektorientierte Programmiersprache, sondern XML ist ein Datenbeschreibungsformat.
Genau. Eine sogenannte Markup-Language, die man halt unterscheiden muss von einer Programming-Language. Da gibt es auch immer wieder dieses allgemeine Missverständnis, dass es dann häufig von HTML-Programmierern die Rede, die irgendwie einem Webseiten erstellen. Wenn man es halt mal sich genau anschaut, stellt man fest, dass es sich bei HTML um eine reine Beschreibung einer Struktur handelt. Nämlich, wie ist meine Webseite aufgebaut? Da habe ich eine Überschrift, da habe ich einen Text, da ist ein Bild und so weiter. Aber es handelt sich nicht um die Ablaufformulierung für ein Programm. Also HTML beschreibt nicht, dass irgendwas 5-mal getan werden soll und in Abhängigkeit davon noch mal oder vielleicht noch mal oder auf eine andere Art und Weise. Das ist das, was halt eine Programming-Language ist, während diese ganzen MLs Markup-Languages sind. Das ist schon was anderes. Das heißt, XML ist eigentlich gedacht, um Daten zu speichern. Und zwar XML, jetzt im Besonderen eben der kräftig aufkommende neue Standard, der so sehr viele Probleme von allgemeinen Speicherformaten, der Frühzeit weitgehend löst. Also da kann man halt Text in allen Sprachen, in Chinesisch, in Japanisch und so weiter reinlegen. Und jeder Computer kann das dann auch korrekt interpretieren, wenn er nicht falsch programmiert ist. Und vor allem kann man halt dort Struktur ablegen, was noch zu den Daten hinzukommt. Das heißt, ich modelliere sowohl die Daten als solche, als auch ihre Bezüge untereinander. Was gehört in was rein? Ich habe eine Liste von 5 Tischen und solche Dinge. Und die kann man dort einfach ablegen und dann auch vergleichsweise einfach in jeder beliebigen Programmiersprache, das muss dann auch keine objektorientierte Programmiersprache sein, weiterverarbeiten.
Aber man könnte die Struktur von XNAS schon als objektorientiert bezeichnen. Du hast die Art und Weise, wie das File aufgebaut ist. Das lässt sich mit der Klasse verbinden. Und dann die tatsächliche Art und Weise, wie das File dasteht. Also die einzelnen Blöcke, das sind sozusagen die Instanzen. Das ist irgendwie ein abzielgültiger Vergleich. Nein, natürlich. Das ist eine objektorientierte Datenstruktur.
Und noch eine abschließende Frage.
Wie bewertet ihr jetzt einen XML-Profi in der Berufswelt, also der das drauf hat, die Daten?
Na ja, gute Berufsaussichten hast du, wenn du dir sowas wie XML, wenn Bedarf besteht, mal eben in ein, zwei Monaten anlesen kannst. Also jetzt nur XML ist für eine Berufskarriere, glaube ich, nicht so entscheidend. Also wenn, dann solltest du eine Reihe von Fähigkeiten mitbringen.
Also gekoppelt mit Administrationen, also.
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn du in den nächsten zwei Jahren noch nicht begriffen hast, was XML ist, dann solltest du überlegen, ob du in den Gartenbau wechselst.
Oder Ami? Ich hab hier nur Ami stehen, so wie französisch Freund. Deswegen hab ich gedacht, das wird doch eine nette Geschichte werden. Aus Magdeburg.
Ich hab mal eine generelle Frage. Und zwar bei der ganzen objektorientierten Programmierung ist ja nicht ein ganz, ganz flimmer Nachteil, der es ja fast unmöglich macht, wirklich realistisch Welten da nachzubilden. Nämlich, wenn ich die Objekte habe und in Klasseninstanzen einteile. Ja, sagen wir mal ein ganz simples Beispiel. Ich hab ein Computerspiel und hab da einen Baum. Dann hab ich doch das Problem, dass jeder Baum irgendwie gleich aussieht. Also wenn ich jetzt Objekte nehme und damit zum Beispiel jetzt virtuelle Realitäten abbilden will, ja, dann hab ich doch immer damit das Problem, dass ich halt einmal zum Beispiel einen Tisch oder irgendeinen Gegenstand klar definiert habe und der dann aber immer wieder in diesen selben Grenzen und mit diesen selben Merkmalen erscheint. Irgendwann wird das Ganze doch dann langweilig.
Naja, das ist gar kein schlechtes Beispiel für was objektorientierte Programmierung eigentlich ist. Nämlich für die meisten Teile eines Programms, das ein Spiel darstellt, ist es völlig egal, wie der Baum aussieht. Man muss bloß wissen, da ist ein Baum, muss möglicherweise in der Lage sein zu testen, ob jetzt ein Objekt mit dem Baum kollidiert oder nicht. Und wie der Baum angezeigt wird, das ist eigentlich nur an einer Stelle relevant, nämlich da, wo er hingemalt wird. Das heißt, man kann sich da prima eine abstrakte Basisklasse Baum machen. Und alle Teile des Programms wissen nur, da ist ein Baum. Und nur der Teil, der das dann hinterher hinmalt, kennt verschiedene Bäume, die verschieden aussehen und so weiter und so fort.
Also ich hab das halt so, ich hab ab und zu ein paar Computerspiele probiert und da fand ich das halt immer ziemlich langweilig. Weil eben gerade wenn so versucht wurde, virtuelle Welten abzubilden, das eben dann doch irgendwie, sah an sich die Objekte immer ein bisschen ähnlich mit der Zeit. Das kriegt man dann irgendwie raus.
Das ist aber kein Problem der objektorientierten Programmierung, sondern das ist ein Problem der mangelnden Liebe zum Detail oder des mangelnden Speicherplatzes auf dem Datenträger für das Spiel oder der mangelnde Zeit, die bei der Programmierung zur Verfügung stand, oder, oder, oder.
Also ihr meint, wenn man Objekte definiert und man kann ihnen also dann immer einzelne Eigenschaften auch zustellen, also wie es im wirklichen Leben auch ist. Weil es ist ja einfach so, kein Objekt in der wirklichen Welt sieht immer gleich aus. Also das hat so viele verschiedene Eigenschaften.
Genau. Und genau darum, und genau weil das so ist, möchte man eben eine Programmierung vorantreiben, die eben an Objekten und zwar in ihrer Eigenschaft, dass sie zwar alle teilweise ähnlich, aber manchmal auch komplett anders sind, dass mir das Programmieren in dieser Denke erlaubt. Deswegen möchte man das eben so machen, während die einfache oder herkömmliche Herangehensweise einfach nur ein Programm zu schreiben, was auf irgendwelchen Daten rumfummelt, es schwer hat, die wirkliche Komplexität der Welt auch brauchbar abzubilden.
Man müsste dann immer wieder Variablen einbauen, die dieses Objekt dann variieren.
Genau so funktioniert das. Ein Objekt ist im Prinzip nur eine Ansammlung der Variablen, die den Zustand des Objektes beschreiben. Jede dieser Ansammlung ist anders. Objektorientierung ist nur der Ansatz, dass man bestimmte Objekte, die gleiche Merkmale aufweisen, in Kategorien zusammenfasst. Wenn du dir irgendwie morgens einen Kaffee kochst, dann ist der Kaffee jedes Mal derselbe, obwohl das eigentlich jedes Mal der andere Kaffee ist. Und deswegen musst du auch nicht weiter drüber nachdenken, sondern kannst es in dich reingießen und warten, dass das Gehirn anfängt zu funktionieren. Und wenn man halt Programme schreibt und das nicht tut, wenn man also tatsächlich irgendwie jede Ansammlung von Daten als etwas Besonderes betrachtet, dann verzettelt man sich sehr schnell. Weil man an jeder Stelle Ausnahmen reinprogrammieren muss und ist es jetzt irgendwie, wenn das hier so ist, dann ist das da so. Das wird unübersichtlich unwartbar, unläsbar, kommt schlechte Software bei raus.
Und was, ist da so eine gute Programmiersprache, die man heutzutage unter Windows oder eben einfach so benutzen kann, um so objektorientiert zu programmieren und gute Übersicht zu behalten?
Also, Programmiersprachen sind immer Gegenstand tiefer religiöser Debatten, was ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat, dass auch das Gehirn jedes Menschen ein bisschen anders funktioniert und jeder Mensch anders geprägt ist und jeder Mensch anders gelernt hat zu denken. Im Endeffekt kann man also nicht sagen, es gibt die optimale Sprache, aber es gibt schon ein paar, die relativ gut sind, die also viele Eigenschaften auf sich vereinen. Unter Windows konkret, es gibt, glaube ich, Smalltalk für Windows von verschiedenen Herstellern. Smalltalk ist eine klassische objektorientierte Sprache, die mal bei Xerox erfunden wurde in den späten 70ern, die sehr sehr schön ist, die auch relativ leicht für Programmiereinsteiger ist, weil es eine interaktive Sprache ist. Das heißt, man kann eine Zeile hinschreiben und die wird direkt ausgeführt. Dann gibt es zum Beispiel Squeak. Genau, Squeak ist interessanterweise von Disney finanzierte Open-Source-Implementierung von Smalltalk. Dann meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache ist ja Dillon. Dillon ist eine Sprache, die auf Lisp beruht, die aber nicht so aussieht wie Lisp. Das heißt, man hat nicht diesen ganzen Klamoritis, sondern es sieht eher Pascal-ähnlich aus. Es hat Vorteile und Nachteile. Der Vorteil ist erstmal, dass man es als Programmierer leichter lesen kann. Da gibt es eine Implementierung von einer Firma namens Functional Objects. Er ist Functional Developer, wo wir schon bei Lisp sind. Common Lisp hat auch ein objektorientiertes Modul, das Common Lisp Object System. Da gibt es mehrere Hersteller. Ich fürchte, das werden wir als komplette Liste auf die Webseite tun müssen. Es hilft jetzt auch nicht, das runter zu beten. Aber so das sind Sprachen, wo du mal gucken solltest. Smalltalk, Gönnen, Common Lisp.
Ich habe beobachtet, ich mache gerade eine Doktorarbeit. Bei uns im Institut haben sie so ein Programm hergestellt, was in der Zeit immer größer wurde, in C++. Oder 3++ dahinter, keine Ahnung. Und da haben die sich völlig verzettelt, weil jetzt hat ein zweiter Programmierer gefragt, was der erste damit zu arbeiten, was der erste inzwischen weggegangene gemacht hat. Der kann überhaupt nicht damit arbeiten. Und die scheinen irgendwie völlig undurchdringliche Programmcodes zu sein, wo man irgendwie die Übersicht...
Das ist bei Programmcodes oft so der Fall, dass sie undurchdringlich sind.
Aber C++ ist eine besonders widerliche objektorientierte Programmiersprache. Weil durch die ganze C-Kompatibilität und Sachen, die dann halt nicht gingen und die er jetzt nicht implementieren konnte und anderes Gesocks, ist es also sehr, sehr schwierig, einen C++ guten objektorientierten Code zu schreiben.
Entschuldigung mal, ganz kurz, weil da vorhin so viele Namen für ihn. C++ ist im Vergleich zu Lisp oder zu Squeak, richtig? Also eher was, was genannt wird, wo man auch eher Bücher im Regal sieht, als zu solchen Sprachen.
Das ändert nichts daran, dass die Sprache totaler Dreck ist.
Das ist wie mit Windows. Nicht das, was am meisten verbreitet ist, hat irgendwie jetzt die höchste Qualität. Also was Andreas genannt hat, ist jetzt nochmal auch unsere Sicht der Dinge, wenn man das objektorientierte Programmieren als solches erlernen möchte, wenn man daran ein Interesse hat. Das andere ist, dass viele Leute programmieren, um etwas Konkretes, nicht selten auch aus wirtschaftlichen, zusammenhängenden Dingen heraus, etwas Konkretes programmieren möchten. Und damit müssen sie halt auch mit anderen irgendwie zusammen. Und dann muss das irgendwie zusammenpassen. Und dann wird man halt häufig gezwungen, das zu nehmen, was der andere auch hat. Und C, C++ hat halt weite Verbreitung, genauso wie jetzt auch Java. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Grund, warum man sich manchmal für eine bestimmte Sprache oder Programmierumgebung entscheiden muss. Bei Java merkt man das jetzt gerade ganz deutlich. Also auch Java ist eine objektorientierte Programmiersprache, die deutlich einfacher zu programmieren ist als C++. Also C++ ist wirklich was für Spezialisten.
Das heißt nicht, dass man das nicht erlernen kann, das kann man schon, aber im Wesentlichen ist man fünf Jahre damit beschäftigt, schmerzvoll herauszufinden, welche Features man tun, nicht umgehen sollte. Und dann bleiben so ungefähr 20% des Sprachstandards übrig. Und damit kann man dann richtig schöne Programme schreiben, die nur leider die anderen 95% der Programmierer, die das nicht seit fünf Jahren machen, nicht mehr verstehen.
Also genau das Problem, was ihr nämlich habt. Bei C++ ist es auch sehr auffällig, dass der Writing Style, also wie ein Programmierer konkret seinen Code schreibt, extrem differieren kann. Während sich bei Java, das es natürlich auch gibt, aber bei Java sich viel, gleich von Anfang an, viel mehr Konventionen für die wichtigsten Dinge am Start waren, sodass eben das Problem verringert wurde.
So, mal gucken, ob der Jens noch dran ist.
Ich wollte was zum Thema Objektorientierte Programmierung sagen.
Da bist du bei uns genau richtig.
Ja, ich programmiere seit überhaupt vielen Jahren. Und was ich festgestellt habe, ist, dass die meisten Leute den Sinn oder was hinter der Objektorientierten Programmierung eigentlich steckt, gar nicht begreifen. Weil es meistens schlecht oder zu kompliziert dargestellt wird. Also ich habe mir auch schon vielen Leuten das erklärt müssen. Und es ist schwer, es ist sehr schwer.
Und warst du mit unseren Erläuterungen bislang zufrieden? Ich meine, wir kennen das Problem ja auch.
Ich habe die Sendung leider nicht von Anfang an gehört. Aber die strukturierte Programmierung ist ein riesengroßes Gegenteil. Es ist ein riesengroßer Gegensatz dazu.
Was programmierst du denn?
Also zurzeit programmiere ich in Java.
Das Problem, was ich glaube, da bestätigt, ist, dass die Leute glauben, dass sie objektorientiert programmieren, automatisch in dem Moment, wo sie Java oder C++ programmieren. Das ist natürlich nicht der Fall. Nur weil du irgendjemand in Java oder C++ programmierst, heißt es nicht, dass das Programm auch objektorientiert ist. Das ist eine Art und Weise, zu programmieren. Java oder C++ helfen einem nur durch sprachliche Besonderheiten oder Hilfsmittel, das möglichst einfach und effizient zu tun. Man kann in jeder beliebigen Sprache auch in Assembler oder Basic objektorientiert programmieren, wenn man sich nur die Datenstrukturen selber schafft. Das geht natürlich ohne Weiteres.
Ich hab festgestellt, die Leute schreiben dann in einer einzelnen Klasse oder in einer einzelnen Methode eben ihren gesamten Programmkurs, sprich dann 200-300 Zeilen. Das hat ja nichts mehr mit objektorientiert zu tun.
Das ist Eingabeverarbeitung, Ausgabe wie vor 100 Jahren.
Und das ist eben das Problem, die Leute richtig zu bekehren, dass es durch objektorientierte Programmierung dann letztendlich viel einfacher wird. Ja, früher hab ich im Prinzip angefangen, auch bunte Grafik-Sachen zu programmieren. Jetzt inzwischen bin ich Student. Allerdings nicht Informatik, sondern Bauingenieurwesen. Und ich sag mal, jetzt hab ich nicht die Zeit zu programmieren, wüsste aber auf der Stelle 10.000 Sachen, die ich gerne in Programmierung umsetzen soll. Wir haben an der Fachhochschule, wo ich studiere, Ur- und Jawa-Kurs. Und da haben wir zum Beispiel so ein Problem angepackt, wie eine Transmission grafisch darzustellen. Da kommt man zum Beispiel auch in Sachen wie mit binären Bäumen und so weiter zu programmieren.
Eine Transmission?
Eine Transmission, ja.
Könntest du mal kurz, also weil ich bin jetzt nicht so eine Transmissionsfan, ich wüsste gar nicht, was das ist.
Eine Transmission ist einfach im Prinzip ein paar Räder, sind paar Riemen dazwischen. Und vorne hat man ein Antriebsrad. Und diese Riemen treiben sozusagen jedes weitere Rad an. Also ein einfaches Problem von der Mechanik.
Übersetzung sozusagen?
Ja, Übersetzung, genau, wie beim Fahrrad.
Früher in den Fabriken war das so, da gab es eine zentrale Dampfmaschine und dann gab es so Transmissionsstrecken, wo zu den Maschinen die Drehbewegung übertragen wurde. Ein großes Problem an dem Informatikstudium in Deutschland ist, dass man das Programmieren nicht so richtig beigebracht kriegt. Wenn man Bauingenieur oder Maschinenbau studiert, also klassische Ingenieursfächer, da kriegt man auch so was mitgeteilt. Problemlösungsstrategien und so weiter und so fort. In den Programmierkursen, wie ich sie kenne, fehlt das in der Regel. Da muss man leider selber arbeiten, sich selbst erarbeiten, obwohl es eigentlich gute Literatur gibt zu dem Thema. Den muss man halt nur finden.
Zumal die meisten Maschinenbauingenieure auch ziemlich einen Horror vor der Programmierung haben. Weil viele eben noch nicht so viel mit dem Computer Berührung hatten und dann gleich programmieren. Das ist stürzenskalter Wasser.
Ja, naja, das ist letzten Endes nicht anderes, als eine Maschine zu bauen. Ein Programm zu schreiben und eine Maschine zu bauen, ist eigentlich genau dasselbe, nur dass man nicht mit physikalischen Objekten zu tun hat, sondern mit Elektronen, die in einem Computer durch die Gegend flitzen. Aber so von der generellen Herangehensweise der Problemlösung ist es dasselbe.
Aber jetzt nach meinem Ernst. Also wenn ich jetzt so klassisch Programmieren gelernt hab und ich mache so einen Text und schreib den so runter, die meisten Leute sind ja so orientiert, weil sie wahrscheinlich einfach auch viel Bücher lesen. Zum Beispiel ein Buch geht von vorne bis hinten durch, die Geschichte entwickelt sich. Wenn ich das objektorientiert schreiben würde, das Buch, würde ja ab dem ersten Satz im Grunde, ich komm einen Mann pinkeln da an einen, und dann steht da Funktion Baum und dann drei Daten dahinter, nämlich grüner Baum, großer Baum, Eiche, bla. Und das muss ich dann aber hinten suchen, weil der Programmblock ganz woanders angeordnet ist, nämlich hinten im Buch im Anhang, guck ich nach, was ist das überhaupt für ein Baum an, den der pinkelt, dann geh ich wieder nach vorne zurück, so wär doch objektorientierte Programmierung zu denken. Weil das ist doch, ich mein, das ist schwer, da muss man erst mal hinkommen, da so zu denken, dass man sich diese ganzen Schnipel hier, weil es zurecht programmiert.
Aber eigentlich ist es einfacher.
Ja, eigentlich!
Genau, genau, das muss man begreifen.
Eigentlich ist Steuererklärung auch ganz einfach, aber da reden wir ein anderes Mal drüber. Ok, danke Tobias. Nee, Tobias war es nicht, das war Jens.
Dann 101, 5.
Wir machen gleich weiter und machen jetzt erst mal kurz Nachrichten. Wir haben es nämlich genau 23.30 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter nachts fällt nur vereinzelt ein bisschen Regen. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 8 bis 5 Grad in Berlin bis 7 Grad zurück. Am Tag zieht von West nach Ost ein Regengebiet durch die Region. Dabei sind vereinzelt Gewitter und Sturmböen möglich. Die Temperaturen liegen bei 9 bis 11 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Kerstin Topp.
In der Bundestag hat am Abend der Einfuhr bereits existierender embryonaler Stammzellen unter strengen Auflagen zugestimmt. Damit scheiterten die Anträge für ein absolutes Importverbot sowie für eine weitgehende Freigabe der Einfuhr embryonaler Stammzellen. Deutschland soll wegen des erwarteten Haushaltsdefizits von 2, 7 Prozent einen sogenannten blauen Brief der EU-Kommission erhalten. Erlaubt sind höchstens 3 Prozent. Frankreich hat Vorschläge zur Überwindung der Nahost-Krise unterbreitet. Dabei favorisiert Paris die Anerkennung eines Palästinenser Staates noch vor der Aufnahme von Friedensverhandlungen. Bundesfamilienministerin Bergmann hat heute den ersten Gesamtdeutschen Kinder- und Jugendbericht vorgelegt. Darin wird vor allem für eine bessere flächendeckende Kinderbetreuung plädiert. Brandenburg will mit einem neuen Arbeitsmarktmodell mehr Jobs für ausgebildete Jugendliche schaffen. Dabei sollen sich zwei Absolventen eine Stelle teilen. Das Arbeitsamt wird den Lohn jeweils auf 80 Prozent aufstocken. Unterm Sport im Viertelfinale, Entschuldigung, im Viertelfinale um den DFB-Pokal gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Hertha BSC, 1. FC Köln 1 zu 2 nach Verlängerung. Bayer Leverkusen 1860 München 3 zu 0 und Schalke 04 Rot-Weiß Oberhausen 2 zu 0. Die Partie Kaiserslautern Bayern München endete 3 zu 5 im Elfmeterschießen. Zuvor stand es 0 zu 0 nach Verlängerung. Entschuldigung, nochmal. In der Basketball-Euro League verlor der deutsche Meister Alba Berlin am Abend beim polnischen Titelträger Slask Breslau mit 66 zu 71. Und die Verkehrsmeldungen Stadtverkehr Berlin A111 Stadtautobahn im Tunnel Ortskern Tegel wegen Bauarbeiten Sperrung der rechten Spur Stadtauswärts Biesdorf Zimmermannstraße zwischen Fortunaallee und an der Wule Vollsperrung bis Ende April und noch eine Meldung von der U-Bahn Die U-Bahnlinie 8 pendelt zwischen Gesundbrunnen und Cottbuser Tor im 20-Minuten-Takt mit Umsteigen am Alexanderplatz Umsteigen müsst ihr auch bei der U-Bahnlinie 5 und zwar am U-Bahnhof Tierpark.
Das wird sehr spontan.
Fritz hat eine neue Sendung.
Da geht das am 10. Da fängt das an.
Der Fritz-Kommunikator, die Deutschstunde im Radio mit Knorkator.
Wir werden euch zeigen, wie man Sätze konkret und korrekt beginnt, weiterführt und zu Ende bringt und was passieren kann, wenn man sie nicht korrekt beginnt, weiterführt oder zu Ende bringt.
Jeden Sonntag zwischen 18 und 19.
Uhr ab 10.
Februar und im Radio Fritz.
Guten Tag, Sie haben's eilig. Das ist doch nicht mein Problem. Ihre Zeit ist Ihnen heilig, doch die Wartezeit extrem. Sie wollen auch nur mit jemand sprechen, aber keiner ist für sie bereit. Ach, das kostet wirklich viel. Und jetzt hängen Sie hier fest. Ja, das ist ein Nerventest. Jetzt haben Sie sicher schon ne Krise. Immerhin bin ich nicht für Elise. Ich bin die Warteschleife. Und sie sind doppelt scheiße.
Also mit die schönste Warteschleifenmusik, die ich jemals gehört habe, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben.
Die ist toll, ne?
Die ihr ja tatsächlich auch als Warteschleifenmusik benutzt, ne?
Genau, wir benutzen die als Warteschleifenmusik, wenn man das Blinken als Haus anruft, dann wenn man Lust hat viel Geld auszugeben, kriegt man zumindest auch noch was Schönes vor.
Diesen Song vorgespielt. Man hört das Chaosradio, wir haben jetzt mittlerweile anderthalb Stunden hinter uns gebracht in Sachen Objektorientiertes Programmieren im Studio der Mitsch, der Andreas, der Tim und der Max. Und, naja, ich würde fast diese Musik nochmal hören wollen, so entspannt, wie ich jetzt bin. Aber darum geht es ja heute Abend nicht. Am Telefon ist der Jens aus Köln sogar, also ein Rheinländer. Meine Ex-Freundin, ich bin auch Rheinländer, muss ich dazu zugeben, hat mal gesagt, dass ihre Mutter ihr gesagt hätte, heirate nie ein Rheinländer. Ich fand das diskriminierend damals. Vielleicht war ich noch zu jung.
Wir haben schon mehrmals gehört, was ist denn die beste Programmiersprache? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die beste Programmiersprache kenne, aber ich kenne eine, die in Europa noch ein bisschen unterschätzt wird.
Jetzt sind wir natürlich alle bis zum Zerreißen gespannt.
Na ja, sie heißt Ruby und das ist so eine Art Perl für objektorientierte Japaner. Das kommt aus Japan und das Hauptproblem war, dass die Dokumentation hauptsächlich auf Japanisch vorhanden war. Jetzt gibt es ein bisschen was auf Englisch, so zwei Bücher und mir gefällt das hervorragend, denn es ist sehr sauber, es ist eine Scriptingsprache. Also eigentlich, wo man früher Perl genommen hätte, so mit Texte, Durchwürfeln und so weiter, da kann man jetzt eine sehr reine objektorientierte Programmiersprache nehmen. Es ist halt von Anfang an ziemlich sauber designt worden. Es gibt irgendwie nichts, was kein Objekt ist in dieser Sprache. Sogar die Zahl 5 ist halt ein Objekt. Es ist eine Instanz der Klasse Integer. Und ich kann darauf dann halt auch Methoden anwenden, zum Beispiel 5-Punkt-Times, um dann halt eine Schleife oder so was zu machen. Es ist von der Art halt ein bisschen ähnlich wie Smalltalk, hat aber auch gleichzeitig so Skripting-Sprachen-Features wie Perl.
Das wollte ich ja mal fragen, weil ich habe mir tatsächlich mal ein Perl-Buch geholt. Ich muss es an dieser Stelle ja zugeben. Und was ist eigentlich eine Skriptsprache? Ich habe nämlich in das Buch nie reingeguckt.
Na eine Skriptsprache ist halt eine Sprache, wo man irgendwie schnell mal Lösungen macht, die dreckig sind und die aber schnell das Problem lösen. Also halt meistens geht es um Textverwurstung oder so was. Also dass man halt irgendwelche Texte hat, die man durch die Mangel nimmt und dann irgendwie im anderen Format wieder raushängt. Zum Beispiel, man hat einen Text, der übers Web reinkommt, der wird dann verwurstet und wird übers Web wieder rausgegeben. Das ist dann dieses CGI-Dings, also Common Gateway Interface.
Also mit dem Begriff Skripting-Sprache verbindet man eigentlich, also die Programmiersprachen sind immer Programmiersprachen und Skriptsprachen sind die Sprachen, die man vor allem versucht immer ad hoc aufzurufen und die man vor allem auch benutzt, um eher kleine Dinge anzustoßen. Das kann natürlich auch komplexere Auswüchse haben, aber vor allem einfache Sachen auf eine einfache Methode schnell zu machen und auch geringen Entwicklungszykos zu haben. Deswegen sind diese Sprachen meist interpretiert. Das heißt, dieser Übersetzungsvorgang, den wir da am Anfang schon hatten mit ich schreibe meinen Code, ich übersetze ihn in ein lauffähiges Programm, dann führe ich das Programm auf. Der verkürzt sich bei einer Skriptsprache, also bei einer interpretierten Sprache auf ich schreibe mein Programm und dann führe ich es sofort aus. Deswegen sind solche Skriptsprachen sehr populär in der Systemadministration, wo man mal eben was automatisieren möchte, andere Kommandos aufrufen oder natürlich im Web. JavaScript ist zum Beispiel ein gutes Beispiel und eben auch für kompliziertere Sachen in Web-Servern zum Beispiel, also um Inhalte in Webseiten zu haben.
Ich halte ja Skriptsprache für eine Marketingerfindung, um Leuten zu verkaufen, das jetzt anzufangen zu programmieren, ohne sie mit dem Wort programmieren zu erschrecken. Und ich glaube, eine abgeschlossene Definition von Skriptsprache gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Nee, gibt es natürlich nicht. Aber halt irgendwie das Interpretierte gehört dazu. Und ja, bisher gehört halt auch irgendwie immer dazu, dass es alles irgendwie total unsauer aussieht und dahin gewurschtet war.
Naja, kennst du Appleskript? Also Appleskript ist ja auch eine Skriptsprache, die wirklich schön ist und gut aussieht und gut lesbar ist und sehr orthogonal ist.
Ja, sicher. Also ihr hattet vorhin schon erwähnt, dass es auch alles irgendwie sehr religiöse Untertöne hat, welche Sprache das beste ist. Aber ja, das fiel mir vor einigen Monaten auf. Ich bin, diese Sprache ist zu mir gekommen, Ruby. Und hauptsächlich war ich von Perl ein bisschen angenervt. Und ich fand hier irgendwie eine Sauberkeit, eine Durchdachtheit vor, wo ich gedacht habe, ja, das war echt mal eine Alternative zu Perl.
Ich hab mir das auch vor kurzem mal ein bisschen angeschaut. In Ruby sind wirklich einige sehr schöne Sachen drin. Vor allem, was du sagst, ist es für Leute, die eigentlich das programmieren müssen, was man mit Perl gut machen kann, was aber halt wie alles in Perl garstig aussieht. Da ist es eine interessante Alternative. Man kann mit regulären Suchausdrücken arbeiten. Man kann sich einfach dann auch Objekte machen. Man kann sowohl einen guten Programmierstier an den Tag legen, als auch eben mal schnell auf alles zugreifen.
Wichtig ist halt, dass man das mit dem Objektorientierten verstanden hat. Da dauert es bei jedem ein bisschen länger, bis dann irgendwie die Erleuchtung kommt. Das finde ich irgendwie wie Zen-Buddhismus. Irgendwann kommt halt die Erleuchtung, da hat man es verstanden. Vorher denkt man, was das für ein Geschwafel. Bei mir war es ein Buch namens Entwurfsmuster von ganz vielen Leuten und der erste heißt Erich Gammer. Das habe ich irgendwie mal gelesen und plötzlich war die Erleuchtung dann da und dann hatte ich auch verstanden, warum ich objektorientiert programmieren will. Bei Peer kann man das halt nur bis zu einer bestimmten Grenze objektorientiert programmieren. Danach wird es irgendwie furchtbar, bei Ruby kann man es von Anfang an.
Ja, Entwurfsmuster sind vielleicht dem einen oder anderen unter dem Begriff Design Patterns geläufig. Das ist ein Begriff, der eigentlich aus der Architektur stammt und der halt im Prinzip nichts anderes ist, als dass man sich erstmal einen Satz von Regeln definiert, um Situationen zu beschreiben, eine sogenannte Pattern-Language, und dann für bestimmte immer wiederkehrende Problemfälle gute Lösungen einfach niederschreibt. Also in der Architektur halt das Pattern Wohnzimmer oder das Pattern Terrasse nach draußen, wo dann jeweils beschrieben ist, wo die in der Praxis auftreten, Probleme liegen und so weiter und so fort. Und Design-Patterns sind besonders geeignet, zusammen mit objektorientierter Programmierung verwendet zu werden, weil die Design-Patterns im Prinzip höhere Abstraktionen beschreiben, die man in der Praxis aus Objekten zusammensetzt. Und ich denke auch, die objektorientierte Programmierung selbst war anfänglich ein Design-Pattern, das man in nicht objektorientierten Sprachen verwendet hat. Also es hat sich einfach eine Art und Weise etabliert, Probleme zu strukturieren, es gab dann ein Pattern und man sieht auch immer wieder die Tendenz, dass das, was früher ein Design-Pattern war, also eine bestimmte Anweisung etwas zu tun, in eine Programmiersprachenprimitive verlegt wird. Das haben wir bei der objektorientierten Programmierung, das gibt es bei einigen anderen Sachen zum Beispiel. Das Singleton-Pattern, das dann in manchen Programmiersprachen, wie auch zum Beispiel Ruby wieder als einzelne Typ auftaucht und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, genau, also ein Design-Pattern Singleton ist dann auch schon in der Sprache drin. Es ist ganz hübsch gewesen, dass die dann mit dem Design der Sprache anfangen konnten, als schon sehr viel über objektorientierte Programmierung bekannt gewesen ist. Und dann nicht alle Fehler noch mal machen mussten.
Die Homepage kannst du ja noch mal nennen?
www.rubylang.org Und irgendwie nicht erschrecken, wenn irgendwie doch die Hälfte der interessanten Texte auf japanisch sind. Aber es kommen immer wieder englische Texte dazu.
Ich glaube auch, dass Ruby durchaus im Kommen ist. Ich würde noch nicht sagen, dass es auf der Schwelle zur Weltrevolution ist, aber es findet auf jeden Fall offensichtlich den notwendigen Unterstützungsgrad, den eine Programmiersprache heute schon braucht. Also eine gewisse Fangemeinde und eine gewisse Aktivität in der Programmierszene, eben diese Sprache auch für das eine oder andere zu nutzen. Und erstmal die wichtigsten Sachen, die man erstmal auch gesehen haben will, bevor man sich wirklich mit einer Programmiersprache beschäftigen möchte.
In Japan ist es so, dass es auf jeden Fall weitaus häufiger benutzt wird, als dieses grauenvolle PAP. Und naja, halt noch ein bisschen hinter Pearl. Aber sowas würde ich mir halt auch für Europa wünschen. Aber da ist halt eine ganz andere Sprachbarriere. Nicht die Programmiersprachbarriere, sondern die natürliche Sprachbarriere.
Meine Frage, ist es nicht einfacher, so eine Skriptsprache zu lernen? Weil das wäre die Frage, die ich habe. Nicht übersetzt werden muss für die Maschine. Das heißt, immer sofort so läuft. Dann bleibt die im Grunde so stehen und jeder kann lesen, was ich programmiert habe. Oder? Sie wird nicht compilert?
Ja, das ist halt auch immer so eine Streitfrage. Wird das gar nicht compilert? Oder vielleicht theoretisch doch ein bisschen? Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall sehr einfach, damit zu entwickeln, weil man gleich die Idee, die man hatte, ausprobieren kann. Ob man damit dann leichter oder besser Lärm zu programmieren, steht auf einem anderen Blatt, würde ich mal sagen.
Okay, aber ich denke, jetzt muss man an der Stelle noch mal sauber unterscheiden. Also interpretiert oder compilert macht erst mal keinen Unterschied für die Leichtigkeit, das Programmieren mit dieser Sprache zu erlernen. Sondern entscheidend ist, ob man sich tatsächlich mit den Bits da ganz unten rumplagen muss oder ob man Konstrukte kriegt, die man direkt verwenden kann. Also ob es sinnvolle Strings gibt, ob die Abstraktionsmechanismen gut sind, ob es einfach ist, da drin zu programmieren. Und auch dieses Interaktivitätsfeature ist nicht unbedingt an eine interpretierte Sprache gekoppelt, sondern man kann auch, gerade in Lisp-Kreisen ist es ja üblich, da gibt es die berühmte REPL-Loop, das ist die Read-Eval-Print-Loop, die das, was man da eingeb nimmt, übersetzt und ausführt. Und ob das jetzt interpretiert wird, oder ob das kurz kompiliert wird und in das laufende Programm reingelinkt wird und dann angesprungen wird, macht für den User keinen Unterschied. Also man kann auch mit kompilierten Sprachen die Interaktivität erreichen.
Kann ich so stehen lassen, ich hab das Wort auch so noch gar nicht aufgeschrieben. Aber meine Frage war eher, ob ich dann, wenn jetzt jemand ein cooles Programm geschrieben hat, das irgendwo zu kriegen ist, ich mir das mal anschauen kann nach dem Motto, ah okay, so hat er das gemacht, weil es eben Open Source ist, dadurch, dass es nicht kompiliert wird.
Das kannst du bei Leuten, die ja auch Interesse daran haben, dass ihre Werke sich verbreiten, hin sowieso immer. Sie werden sowieso immer den Source dazu packen, ob der jetzt halt irgendwie in Dillen ist oder in Ruby, das ist dann irgendwie auch eher egal.
Hast du noch eine Anregung, Jens?
Ja, dieses Buch über die Entwurfmuster, Design Patterns, ist vielleicht doch sinnvoller zu lesen, wenn man was über objektorientierte Programmierung lernen will, als jetzt irgendwie, wie lerne ich Java in 21 Tagen.
Ein hervorragendes weiteres Buch, was man direkt dazu empfehlen muss, ist das Buch Refactoring von Martin Fowler. Ist vom selben Verlag, aus derselben Buchreihe. Refactoring ist im Prinzip eine Technik mit objektorientiertem Code umzugehen und Features hinzuzufügen in den Code, ohne die Eleganz des Designs zu verschlechtern. Also Refactoring beschreibt im Prinzip, wie man den Code aufräumt, wie man die Funktionalität einsammelt, neue Abstraktionen einzieht, alles an die richtige Stelle tut, sodass wieder hinterher ein glattes, gesamtes, ganzes rauskommt, was nicht zahackstückelt aussieht. Also die beiden Bücher sollte man eigentlich gelesen haben, um objektorientierte Programmierung wirklich zu verstehen.
Okey dokey. Telefon ist hoffentlich noch, wenn er gewartet hatte, Tobias aus Michendorf. Morgen, Tobias.
Moin, moin, bin noch da.
Fast schon moin. Wir haben es ja noch kurz vor 12.
Naja, ich sag immer moin. Ihr habt doch vorhin was zu den Büchern gesagt.
Vor einer Sekunde.
Ja, weil er von schlechten Büchern gesprochen hat. Ich hab hier eigentlich ein ganz gutes Detail an sich auch schon, objektorientierte Programmierung. Ist zwar schon eine Weile alt, aber es ist nicht nur auf eine Sprache bezogen.
Von wem ist das?
Das ist Ahrens und Fischer, sind die beiden Hauptautoren. Welcher Verlag? Verlag Technik GmbH Berlin München. Also ist schon sehr alt eigentlich.
Das sollte er ja bei Standardwerken nichts zu sagen. Oder bei wissenschaftlichem Wissen.
Wenn er recht gehabt hat, hat er bestimmt auch schon damals recht gehabt. Also, das kann gut sein. Und was ist die Herangehensweise des Buches? Was hast du daraus herausnehmen können?
Also, ich hab dir ja schon vorher... Weil sie hat eigentlich... Ja, ich hab immer so ein bisschen Probleme, mich auch zu drücken. Es hat... Es baut eigentlich erst mal auf, was ist eine Klasse und dann die einzelnen Abschnitte bis hin zu Polymorphie. Dann gibt's mehrere Beispiele, einmal in Pascal und einmal in C++. Also, das ist eigentlich ganz gut aufgebaut, aber ich hatte auch schon mal ein Desaster mit einem Buch, was ich mir ausgeliehen hatte, war von Markt und Technik oder so ähnlich. Und das war eigentlich nur Werbung für ein eigenes Multi-User-Dungeon-Spiel.
Ja, dem verlag Markt und Technik sonst sollte man weiträumig meiden.
Echt? Also, ich hab früher mal Empfehlungen bekommen, weil die so toll schreiben, Bücher von Markt und Technik.
Kann durchaus mal sein, dass auch Markt und Technik...
Rätselrechnungen sind ganz gut, aber ansonsten...
Kann durchaus sein, dass da auch irgendwie mal ein tolles Buch rausgekommen ist, aber sie sind auf gar keinen Fall als Garant für hervorragende Literatur bekannt.
Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, so ein Buch wie Refactoring, das ist ja vom Titel schon so unsexy, dass ich, wenn ich das sehen würde, würde ich denken, ne, also Refactoring nun gar nicht.
Den Titel findest du unsexy?
Ich finde den total sexy.
Wenn man sich damit beschäftigt, dass das Buch dann alles gut befunden hat, aber ich meine, kann jemand, der wirklich mit Programmieren anfängt, mit so einem Buch was anfangen, oder ist das was, wenn einer jetzt schon mal eine Programmiersprache benutzt hat und will sich jetzt darauf spezialisieren, was ist wirklich objektorientiertes Programmieren, also eher so?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall Second Stage. Aber die kann ja auch relativ schnell kommen. Also wenn man das lernen will, es ist ja eigentlich ganz einfach. Man kann das ja gar nicht häufig genug betonen. Diese ganze Sache mit den Computern, das ist 0, 1 und Logik. Und wenn man irgendwie in der Lage ist, sich seinen Weg von der Wohnzimmertür irgendwie zum nächsten Kiosk irgendwie abstrakt zu erschließen, dann kann man auch genauso gut andere Probleme lösen. Und das kann man dann auch mit einem Computer, wenn man sich halbwegs anstrengt.
Apropos abstraktion in der Natur. Mir ist mal aufgefallen, ich bin ja 10. Klasse, hatten wir ja gerade im Bio diesen Mist. Wenn man da mal guckt, eigentlich ist alles abstrakte Basis-Klasse aufgebaut. Ganz oben natürlich abstrakte Basis-Klasse Lebewesen. Geht dann runter bis zur Art oder so weiter und nur davon gibt es dann Instanzen.
Völlig richtig. Und genau, abstrakte Basis-Klassen. Hier sind ein paar Begriffe gefallen. Polymorphie habe ich auch gehört. Das sollte man die Gelegenheit nutzen und auch erklären. Also Polymorphie ist die Eigenschaft eines Programmes, mit Objekten so umzugehen, dass es egal ist, was denn jetzt konkret dafür ein Objekt dasteht, wenn es ausreicht, die dazugehörige abstrakte Basis-Klasse zu kennen. Also bei unserem beliebten Flaschenbeispiel ist halt die abstrakte Basis-Klasse Flasche mit Getränk drin. Und da gibt es dann die Polymorphie-Methode, draus zu trinken. Und wie genau das Trinken jetzt aussieht, das kann von der konkreten Flasche abhängen. Und das interessiert mich aber nicht in dem Moment, wo ich da beim Programmieren tatsächlich hinschreibe. Flasche, Punkt, Trinke, Klammer auf, mein Mund, Klammer zu. Polymorphie ist sicherlich eine der grundlegendsten Eigenschaften von objektorientierter Programmierung. Es gibt da noch so ein paar andere Eigenschaften, wie zum Beispiel das mit der Kapselung. Und auch Single Dispatch, Multiple Dispatch, die sind bei vielen Sprachen verschieden. Polymorphie ist eine grundlegende Eigenschaft. Wenn die nicht da ist, spricht man eigentlich nicht von objektorientierter Programmierung.
Hier sind in dem Buch ein paar Pascal-Beispieler. Also Pascal 5.5. Polymorphie habe ich da nicht viel gefunden, aber es hat mich schon gewundert, dass Pascal objektorientiert ist. Das ist das Normale.
Das ist nicht das normale Pascal, sondern das ist Turbo Pascal 5.5. Und das ist objektorientiert. Das heißt ja mittlerweile auch Delphi nicht mehr Pascal.
Ich meine das richtige alte Turbo Pascal 5.5.
Turbo Pascal 5.5, ja ja. Das ist im Prinzip noch dasselbe wie Delphi. So wenn man sich mal die Geschichte anguckt. Und Turbo Pascal 3.0 war noch ohne Objekte. Und irgendwann haben sie halt Objekte zusätzlich reingebaut, so wie bei C++ die Objekte mal zusätzlich reingebaut waren. Also ein C mit reingebauten Objekten quasi.
Ich mache jetzt C++. Bin auch ganz zufrieden, man braucht aber ein Forum, um sich auszutauschen zu können.
Ja, das braucht man eigentlich immer.
Gibt es eigentlich auch nicht objektorientierte Sprachen? Gibt es die noch? Weil das hört sich irgendwie so an, als wäre die Zukunft ganz klar da zu suchen.
Genau, also C ist vielleicht das beste Beispiel. So, C ist einfach eine sehr verbreitete Programmiersprache, in der auch die meisten gängigen Betriebssysteme weitgehend erstellt, zumindest wurden, dann sind sie teilweise auf C++ weitergeführt worden oder auf anderen Derivaten von C. Und C erlaubt natürlich wie jede Programmiersprache auch mir einen objektorientierten Blick auf die Dinge zu machen, aber es unterstützt einen dabei nicht besonders, sodass man eben nicht sagen kann, das ist eine objektorientierte Programmiersprache. Da gibt es eine klare Unterscheidung Code und Daten und ich mach damit halt was.
Also C++ ist glaube ich noch eine hybride Sprache.
Genau, ähnlich wie Tor Pascal 5.5.
Wo ich aber sagen würde, C++ ist schon mehr objektorientiert als Pascal. Weitaus mehr.
Ja, aber es fängt schon bei so ganz einfachen Sachen an, wie, okay, heißt objektorientiert, dass es gibt auch Objekte oder ich orientiere mich wirklich am Objekt und das heißt, es gibt nur Objekte.
Da kommt es auf den Programmierer an, würde ich sagen.
Naja, da kommt es natürlich auch auf die Programmiersprache an, weil wenn du sowas hast wie eine Zahl, eine 15, dann ist das halt in C++ kein Objekt und das ist auch in Java kein Objekt. Die Frage ist bloß, warum soll ausgerechnet eine Zahl kein Objekt sein? Das führt nämlich dann dazu, dass ich mit Zahlen anders arbeite als mit Objekten, aber ich will eben genau das nicht.
Ja, kommt drauf an, man kann sich ja ein Objekt Zahl machen und dann eben als Hauptelement eben 15 reinbauen.
Ja, aber der ganze Code, den nur irgendwie, ich meine, kein Mensch benutzt die 15 in C++ irgendwie als Objekt. Und wenn er das macht, dann hat er gleich wieder das Problem, dass es mit den anderen nicht so ohne Weiteres zusammenkommt.
Muss man die hinterher konvertieren, das ist elend.
Das willst du nicht.
Zusätzliche Schreibarbeit. Also es geht ja bei Programmiersprachen immer drum, dass einem möglichst viel Arbeit erspart bleibt, Sachen immer wieder hinzuschreiben, sondern man möchte halt dem Computer einen gewissen Sachverhalt genau einmal mithangen und das soll gefällig streichen. Und Sprachen wie C++ sind einem da keine große Hilfe. Na ja, ein paar Sprachen hatten wir schon genannt. Also Smalltalk ist sehr interessant. Python ist auch eine sehr beliebte Skriptsprache, die objektorientiert arbeitet. Dillon, Common Lisp.
Wie schreibt man eigentlich Dillon?
Dillon, Dynamic Language. D-Y-L-A-N.
Was ist denn noch wichtig? Was ist denn noch schick und in?
Na ja, was ist denn mit deinem G-Lib zum Beispiel? Das könntest du ja auch mal. Es gibt natürlich viele Leute, die nach wie vor in C programmieren und auch weiterhin in C programmieren wollen und auch nicht in C++ programmieren wollen, aber auch Objekte wollen. Da gibt es noch einen Gnome Ansatz.
Mein persönliches Fibrate ist nämlich einfach C. Weil C ja keine Objekte bietet irgendwie, braucht man eine Zusatzbibliothek. Das ist in meinem Fall die G-Lib. Das ist auch eine schicke Abstraktionsleihe, die auch irgendwie auf Windows und auf sonstigen Plattformen funktioniert. Das ist im Prinzip einfach C mit einer schicken Library drauf. Und ich finde den Vorteil bei so einer expliziten Schreibweise, wie man das dann halt nötig hat, man hat halt keinen Syntactic Sugar, der einem ermöglicht, kurz mal Object Create oder so hinzuschreiben, sondern man muss halt wirklich tatsächlich hinschreiben, was man tut. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Pointer refnen will, muss ich hinschreiben, G Object Ref zum Beispiel. Also ich sehe wirklich alles, was ich tue.
Was meinst du mit Pointer refnen?
Irgendein Objekt.
Aber es hat nicht gesummt.
Ich hab, also da bin ich nicht drauf gekommen. Das war zu deep, um auch mal so ein Wort gebrochen zu können. Ein Pointer-Referenz. Also ich würde mir ja vorstellen, das heißt einem Punkt eine Referenz zuweisen oder so was, wenn ich da die Abkürzungen auslese.
Eine bestehende Referenz nachvollziehen.
Oder so.
Also das mit dem Pointer refnen ist eine spezielle Technologie des Garbage Collection. Also programmiert kennt das Problem, man muss Speicher alluzieren und muss ihn dann wieder freigeben. Und Garbage Collection heißt, dass man den Speicher nicht mehr freigibt, sondern einfach rumliegen lässt. Und ab und zu kommt dann der Müllmann vorbei und sammelt den Garbage ein und schmeißt ihn weg. Und da gibt es verschiedene Technologien für eine ist Referenz Counting. Jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendwo das Objekt benutze, also wenn ich es referenziere, wenn ich einen Pointer da drauf habe, zähle ich meinen Zähler um eins hoch. Und wenn ich die Referenz nicht mehr habe, weil die Funktion zu Ende ist und ich den Pointer nicht mehr brauche, dann zähle ich den Zähler wieder eins runter. Und wenn es bei Null angekommen ist, weiß keiner mehr, dass das Objekt existiert, also keine Stelle im Programm kennt das Objekt noch, also kann es auch weggeworfen werden. Es gibt auch fortschrittlichere Technologien, die das automatisch machen, wo man sich nicht mehr darum kümmern muss. Und die sind dann aber in der Regel in Sprachen, die nicht dafür ausgelegt wurden, schwieriger zu nutzen. Auch in C geht das mit der Garbage Collection, mit der Spezial Library, die hat gewisse Nachteile dafür.
Das lenkt man nicht ab. Ich würde noch ein bisschen mehr über das Modell mit der G-Lib hören. Das ist halt eine interessante Verheiratung. Auf der einen Seite will man eigentlich Objekte pur, auf der anderen Seite möchte man irgendwie den Maximalfeind des Objekts, nämlich C.
Ich finde den Ansatz nicht schlecht, weil C ist ja so, ich würde sagen, die allerunterste Abstraktionsebene, die mich von der Maschinencode wegbringen.
Das ist ein portabler Assembler.
Das ist ein portabler Assembler im Prinzip. Und auf diesem portablen Assembler kann ich, wenn ich mir ein bisschen Mühe gebe und ein geeignetes Hilfsmittel habe, einen Code schreiben, der Maschinen unabhängig ist, das natürlich noch compilert werden muss für die jeweilige Maschine und der also richtig amtlich Objekte benutzt. Und ich finde die Herangehensweise in den Library zu nehmen gar nicht schlecht, weil das ist immer so das Problem. Es ist jetzt so ein von vorne rein festgelegter Ansatz. Ich definiere eine Sprache, ich denke mir die fünf Features aus, die Forschung kennt gerade Singletons und Polymorphie und Dinge. Das alles kommt in die Sprache rein, dann wird die Sprache benutzt, es gibt Programme in der Sprache und dann fällt mir ein Jahr später ein, ich hätte aber auch noch gerne jetzt dynamische Parameter an dem Objekt dran hängen. Also muss ich die Sprachdefinition ändern. In dem Fall von Gleb, da ändere ich nur die Bibliothek und die Programme sind wesentlich leichter anpassbar, weil sie ja immer noch reines C sind.
Wobei gerade Lisp ja bewiesen hat, dass das kein Widerspruch ist. Also Lisp wurde auch schon 1958 erfunden und ist trotzdem objektorientiert, weil sie durch relativ mächtige Makros, die in die Sprache eingebaut sind, die nicht auf Textsetzungsebene arbeiten, sondern direkt auf der Syntax der Sprache arbeiten, alle neuen Features, die so erfunden wurden, einfach implementieren konnten als Library.
Wo gibt es einen G-Lib für Windows, also speziell für DJI GPP?
Das ist dieser GCC für Windows.
Das gibt es einfach auf www.gtk.org.
Ach so. Ach es, ähm, gibt's.
Das ist irgendwie die Grundbasis der Gnome Modulkommunikation innerhalb des Gnome-Systems, also diesem einen von den beiden populären Desktop-Projekten, die es so für die Unix-Welt gibt. Wobei da auch ganz interessant ist der Ansatz, also beide, das andere ist KDE, beide möchten halt gerne so objektorientiert sein, wie es nur irgendwie geht. So, also die haben schon verstanden, dass man irgendwie objektorientiert sein muss, um da überhaupt irgendwas zu reißen. Und während der Ansatz bei KDE der ist, wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal C++ und legen los, ist es bei Gnomen eben irgendwie, wir gehen mal wirklich von dem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner aus und bauen uns dann aber eine Bibliothek, die weitgehend wiederverwendbar ist, auch von anderen Programmiersprachen. Womit natürlich das Gnomen-Modell sehr viel offener ist, für Objektinteraktion auch Programmiersprachen übergreifend. Also man programmiert objektorientiert, aber man tut es gar nicht mal nur im Kontext einer einzigen Sprache.
Das ist ein weiterer Vorteil von C. Man kann, wenn man eine C-Library geschrieben hat, also eine Bibliothek, die Funktionen zur Verfügung stellt, einfach mit einfachsten Hilfsmitteln jede andere Sprache dazulenken. Während es mit C++ leicht haarig bis unmöglich ist.
Also das ist auch der eigentliche Hintergrund hinter diesem Streit Gnomen vs. KDE. Also man kriegt das ein bisschen am Rande mit. Es gibt da diese zwei Desktop-Systeme und Außenstehende fragen sich so ein bisschen, warum. Sind die nicht in der Lage, sich mal zu einigen und irgendwie zusammen ein Projekt zu machen? Machen sie sie so zerstritten oder was? Und der wirkliche Grund ist halt, KDE ist in C++ und es gibt halt eine ernstzunehmende Menge Programmierer da draußen, die alles programmieren würden, wenn sie kein C++ programmieren müssen. Die programmieren halt alle am Gnomen-Projekt mit. Und dadurch, dass man mit C-Interface-Libraries in alle Sprachen schreiben können, sind da halt auch 15 bis 20 Sprachen vertreten mit Bindings für Gnomen, während man bei KDE halt genau C++ hat. Ja, ist eine schreckliche Sprache.
Okay, da hab ich nämlich momentan auch ein Problem. Ich wollte nämlich mit einem Kumpel ein Projekt für Jugendforscht machen. Mein Problem ist, weil er in Delphi programmiert, wollte ich ihm für mein Projekt ein paar Klassen bauen, die ich ihm dann gebe. Aber als ich nur die DLL mache, sind einfach nur die Funktionen drin und diese bekloppten Namen natürlich.
Das ist ein großes Problem, was du da ansprichst. Also wenn zwei Leute in unterschiedlichen Programmiersprachen programmieren, ist es ziemlich schwierig wirklich funktionierende Umgebungen zu finden, wo man die volle Objektfähigkeit der einen Programmiersprache der anderen auch bereitstellen kann.
Es gibt in der Regel so Kommunikationsbibliotheken, die so was wie den kleinsten gemeinsamen Objektnänner miteinander kommunizieren lassen. Also Corber ist ein Beispiel dafür, wo man einfach eine Interface-Definition hat und sich dann für dieses Interface in mehreren Sprachen bindings programmieren kann, um dann die Objekte auch von einer anderen Sprache oder auch von einem anderen Rechner nutzen zu können. d.com ist glaube ich das Äquivalent aus der Windows Welt, wo es auch so was wie Objekte gibt und Methoden, die man da drauf aufrufen kann.
Aber keine Klassen.
Es hat halt alles seine Nachteile und man muss auch, wie das bei Rappern so ist, auch dann nochmal zu Fuß was hin programmieren. Es reicht nicht aus, das Objekt fertig zu programmieren, sondern man muss dann noch das Binding zu Korber oder zu DCom hin programmieren.
Das nervt.
Ich denke mal mein Problem ist eigentlich nur, dass ich nicht den richtigen Compiler hab, der mir dann die Objekte mit in die DLL reinbaut.
Nee, das geht nicht. Das ist einfach eine Sprachbarriere. Die Objekte existieren nicht mehr in der DLL, sondern die Objekte existieren sozusagen in Anführungszeichen nur im Gedächtnis des Compilers. Und wenn da erstmal eine DLL draus geworden ist, gibt es nur noch Funktionen.
Die DLL ist eine Library.
Dynamic Link Library ist eine Programmbibliothek, also ein Stück Programm, was für sich genommen kein vollständiges Programm ist, sondern was Programme hinzunehmen, um eine bestimmte Fähigkeit noch hinzubekommen.
Weil da so viele von diesen Begriffen fallen, das sind irgendwie so Sachen, die immer ein ähnliches Ding beschreiben, deswegen, ich komm sowieso schon seit 5 Minuten nicht mehr wirklich mit, aber Makros, Libraries, Klassen, Bindings, die ganze Mischpoke. Eine Library ist ja im Grunde so was, wie man sich vorstellt, eine Bücherei, in der ich verschiedene Klassen dann untergebracht habe, oder was ist da zu finden?
Funktionen und Daten, aber keine Klassen mehr.
Keine Klassen?
Weil das sind ja sozusagen nur für den Code sichtbar und für den Compiler. Am Ende kommt sowieso alles wieder auf Assembler zurück und einfach...
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wie man den Begriff verwendet. Also wenn man Library sagt und damit eine DLL meint, da sind keine Objekte mehr drin. Aber es gibt natürlich auch Libraries auf Programmiersprachenebene.
Klassenbibliotheken.
Klassenbibliotheken. Und da ist eigentlich auch eine der Stärken von objektorientierter Programmierung, nämlich die Wiederverwendbarkeit. Man programmiert sich halt einmal eine Klassenbibliothek, die die Funktion hat und kann die dann in vielen Programmen wiederverwenden.
Das war was vorhin Mitch erzählt hat, dass man die Library dann verändert und dann hat man auf einmal dynamische Schnipel da drin oder so. Richtig?
Ja, aber das falle ich unter anderem hinaus.
Also das, was da halt bei einer DLL fehlt ist, dieses Klasseninterface, also die Beschreibung der Klassen und der Methoden in einer anderen Programmiersprache übernehmen zu können. Man ist halt irgendwie, wenn man einmal eine Klassenbibliothek hat, ist die für eine Sprache nutzbar, letzten Endes.
Ja, es gibt, es ist auch ein, ich kann auch nochmal was hinzu, es gibt natürlich auch neue Trends, auch, sagen wir mal, Fähigkeiten des Betriebssystems allen laufenden Programmen auch auf eine objektorientierte Natur entgegenzubringen. Apple verfolgt das zum Beispiel in seinem neuen Betriebssystem Micro S10. Dort sind halt die Systemfunktionalitäten selber auch als Framework, also als objektorientierte Programmierbibliothek bereitgehalten, sodass man eben sehr viel auch wiederverwenden kann und sehr einfach relativ komplexe Dinge des Betriebssystems mit in sein Programm hinein erben und leicht wiederverwenden und anpassen kann. Aber auch da gibt es genau diese Sprachenbarriere, weil wenn man halt so komplex sozusagen abstrahlt, dann muss man natürlich auch entsprechend aufgenommen werden. Und deswegen kann man derzeit das System auch nur mit zwei Programmiersprachen machen. Das eine ist Java und das andere ist Objective-C, was auch so eine C-Variante mit Objekten ist.
Aber nicht zu verwechseln mit C++, weil die haben ganz verschiedene, sozusagen, Basen. Also ich hab hier zufällig eine Tabelle liegen. Also Objective-C stammt direkt von Smartalk ab, aber C von BCPL.
Also Objective-C hat fast nichts mehr mit C zu tun.
Also Objective-C ist schon der erste, eigentlich ist er ein ähnlicher Ansatz wie die G-Libs. Man nimmt einfach das C, so wie es ist, und dann baut man sich komplett daneben einfach noch mal ein Objektsystem auf. Wobei die sich im Wesentlichen an Smartalk orientiert haben. Das heißt, das Objektsystem und auch so die Schreibweise in Objective-C ähnelt sehr Smalltalk. Smalltalk ist halt eine ausschließlich objektorientierte Programmiersprache, so ein Prinzip die reine Lehre. Das ist Smalltalk, das ist nicht irgendeine Programmiersprache, sondern das ist eigentlich nicht irgendeine OO-Sprache, sondern das ist irgendwie eine objektorientierte Programmiersprache, die wirklich so den Standard gesetzt hat für was wirklich objektorientiert ist. Obwohl es vorher schon solche Ideen gab. Aber erst mit Smalltalk hat sich das so richtig manifestiert. Und in der C-Welt, wo man halt immer schön nah an der Maschine ist und wo es manchmal ja auch ganz schön ist, dass man so schön nah an der Maschine ist, nervt das eben, dass man eben so weit weg von der Abstraktion von Objekten ist. Und deswegen gab es eben verschiedene Methoden ranzugehen. Im Wesentlichen halt Objective-C, das war eine relativ kleine Gruppe. Im Wesentlichen diese Next-Truppe, die das vorangetrieben hat. Dann halt die große Gruppe C++ oder eben jetzt auch G-Lab. Und dann hat, glaube ich, das ist eigentlich dieses C-Sharp von Microsoft. Da hat sich das schon mal einer angeschaut.
Na, das ist so ein bisschen wie Java, hat noch ein, zwei Features mehr.
Ich würde sagen Mixer aus C++ und Java, würde ich sagen.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich eher eine Mischung aus Windows und Java, würde ich sagen. Also Java muss man aber eigentlich auch noch mit reinnehmen. Obwohl es so mit C gar nicht mehr so viel zu tun hat, merkt man schon stark den, ja, man merkt schon ganz stark den Einfluss. Auf jeden Fall.
Um was würdet ihr mir eigentlich für eine Sprache empfehlen?
Um was zu tun? Können wir uns nur wiederholen.
Ja, es gibt darauf keine ultimativ richtige Antwort. Es hängt immer davon ab, was für eine Sorte Programmierer du bist, was für ein konkretes Problem du zu lösen hast, was es noch so für Nebenbedingungen gibt. Also brauchst du zum Beispiel eine existierende Library, um irgendetwas zu tun. Kommt die Sprache deiner Denkweise nahe oder nicht? Und die Sprache hat man schon aufgezählt.
Smalltalk ist halt sehr interessant.
Smalltalk, Ruby, Lisp, Dillon.
Auch Java.
Auch Java kann man sich mal angucken. Längst nicht so viele Features wie andere Sprachen, ist aber ein guter Einstieg.
Aber wenn ich jetzt nicht 89 Mark 90 für jeweils das neueste Buch oder das schönste oder das tollste Englischsprachige, was ja meistens der Fall ist, ausgeben möchte, möchte aber trotzdem feststellen, welche dieser Programmiersprachen meinem Geist am zuträglichsten ist. Wie soll ich das denn feststellen?
Na, da gibt es das Internet. Da steht eigentlich alles drin. Da muss man sich auch erstmal nicht ein Buch kaufen für 69 Mark.
Da gibt es auch was Cooles, wenn man sich mal Code angucken will von verschiedenen Programmiersprachen zu ein und denselben Problem. Muss man irgendwo nach...
Nein, nein, Bottles of Beer?
Genau das.
Ja, das ist ein guter Tipp.
Ja, hab ich mir alle runtergeladen. Richtig klasse.
Also das Schöne daran ist, dass auch für den Leinen unmittelbar nachvollziehbar ist, was das zu lösende Problem ist. Nämlich einfach diesen Song, 99 Bottles of Beer und so weiter. 99 Bottles of Beer, take one down, pass it around, 98 Bottles of Beer und so weiter. Also einfach dieselbe Strophe. Es wird runtergezählt bis Null und dann ist vorbei. Und kann man sich leicht vorstellen. Und wenn man sich dann die Programme anguckt, wie hanebüchen das teilweise ist, welche Kopfstände man machen muss, um so elementare Operationen wie Stringen auszugeben zu tun, dann wird einem auch schnell klar, wo die Unterschiede zwischen den Programmiersprachen liegen. Wo also eher darauf geachtet wurde, wie steuere ich die Maschine oder wo überlegt wurde, wie komme ich denn dem Programmierer dabei entgegen, da strukturiert was hinzuschreiben.
Das sollte man auch noch darauf hinweisen. Es handelt sich hierbei um eine Webseite, die heißt 99 Bottles of Beer. Über Google schnell zu finden. Die Uhr habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf. Und geht halt daraus hervor, dass irgendjemand mal den gesamten Text von 99 Bottles of Beer komplett ausgeschrieben, bis zur letzten heruntergezählt in einer News Group gepostet hat oder eine Mailingliste. Daraufhin kam halt irgendwie einer auf die Idee, sowas kann man ja auch in der Programmiersprache machen. Was war das, das Basic Program?
Das war eigentlich eher so ein, was bist du denn für ein Idiot? Und man hätte ja auch dieses Basic Program posten können.
Genau so. Dann hat er halt ein Programm geschrieben, was irgendwie exakt denselben Text Output macht. Dann kam der nächste und hat es in seiner Programmiersprache gemacht. Dann kam noch einer, noch einer, noch einer. Irgendwann hatte er dann echt 99 Programmiersprachen zusammen. Mittlerweile ist die Liste angewachsen auf, keine Ahnung, 250 oder so. Man findet dort... Brainfuck und was ich auch sehr empfehlen kann, ist Intercal. Irgendwie eine Programmiersprache, der man mehr als 50% des Quotes mit Please do anführen muss, damit er das macht. Aber bloß nicht mehr als 80%, weil das funktioniert jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Intercal ist die einzige Sprache, wo es nicht GoTo gibt, sondern ComeFrom.
Das ist sozusagen einfach eine Verappelung von anderen Programmiersprachen.
Eine der Verappelungen, es gibt da ja auch mehrere.
Oder ich hab irgendwo mal ein Spaßcode von Windows gefunden. Da war C geschrieben, Auskommentiert willkommen zu Windows 3.1. Nächste Zeile auskommentiert willkommen zu Windows 95. Nächste Zeile print, willkommen zu Windows 98.
Also, ich finde die Tatsache bemerkenswert, dass man in Programmiersprachen Witze reißen kann. Das verdeutlicht eigentlich schon ziemlich, dass Programmcode genauso an den menschlichen Leser wie an den Compiler gerichtet ist.
Ich hab irgendwo mal auf der GNU Seite, gnu.org unter Humor oder so ähnlich, ist auch ein ziemlich langer Code. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, da sind Funktionen, wo man English T oder so ähnlich, Make English T oder so ähnlich, Funktionen ist auch ganz witzig. Das dann am Ende einfach darin endet, dass Bill Gates und Linus Torwald gegenseitig ziemlich runtergemacht werden.
Der muss neu sein, das letzte Mal, als ich mir das eingeguckt habe, gab es das noch nicht.
Es gibt viele Ausprägungen von Code Poetry. Zum Beispiel gibt es einen Wettbewerb, der das unlesbarste Programm, was aber trotzdem doch etwas Sinnvolles tut, schreiben kann, wo dann irgendwie das Ding aussieht, wenn man auf den ersten Blick drauf steht, sieht es aus wie eine Lokomotive. Wenn man es startet, merkt man, es gibt irgendwie Schu-Schu-Schu-Schu-Schu-Aus, oder was war das?
Alles mögliche.
Das fällt mir noch dazu ein, unlesbare Programm oder da fällt mir ein, unmögliche Programme. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, ein Programm zu schreiben, was einen eigenen Text, was einen eigenen Code ausgibt?
Ja, das gibt es. Das ist eine Standardprogrammieraufgabe. Die eigentliche Herausforderung ist natürlich für eine spezifische Programmiersprache, das kürzeste Programm zu finden, das sich selber ausgibt.
Na ja, mir ist da was in den Sinn gekommen. In dem Buch, das ich habe, das ist Go2C, also von Edison und Wesley, war eine Möglichkeit drin, dass man einfach über ein System Cut geht, also oder Type, also einfach mal den eigenen Quelltext ausgibt.
Das ist geschummelt. Das zählt nicht.
Ja, das wäre metamäßig, aber eine Möglichkeit wäre, eine Konstante zu nehmen, die man aber dann erst mit einem Makro definiert. Beim Compiler.
Ja, also der übliche Trick ist halt, da ein Printf-Statement zu nehmen, wo zweimal der übergebene String ausgegeben wird. Und das haut dann, wenn man ein bisschen bastelt, genau hin.
Also meine Version wäre gewesen, einfach eine Direktive nehmen, die man dann vorher beim Kompilieren mit Minus D und dann den ganzen Text...
Das funktioniert nicht, weil auch diese Definition muss ja da drin stehen, auch die muss ausgegeben werden. Also du musst schon den kompletten Programmcode ausgeben, das ist die Herausforderung dabei.
Ja, ein kompletter Programmcode wäre zwei Zeilen. Also erstmal den Standard include, damit man erst mal Printed verwenden kann.
Das darfst du auch so. Also bei der besonderen Aufgabe musst du nicht include.
Ja, aber dann einfach das Main in eine Zeile. Diese sozusagen dann kopieren und dann beim Kompilieren einfach hinter das Define dann diese Konstante, die man beim Printen verwendet hat. Einfach so definieren, dass der gesamte Quelltext nochmal da drin steht.
Ja, bastelt hin, das könnte funktionieren. Viel Spaß dabei.
Wer das mitgeschrieben hat, vielleicht funktioniert es gar nicht. Nachlesen kann man es bestimmt irgendwo im Internet. Und damit ich mein, unter unseres Programm hier, unser Programm nochmal wiedergeben kann. Ja, das wäre cool. Warum nicht? Habt ihr eine E-Mail-Adresse wahrscheinlich, ne? CCC.de. Um das Programm nochmal wieder zu geben, es geht um objektorientiertes Programmieren. Und man muss, wenn man hier anrufen möchte, lange nicht so kompliziert einsteigen. Man kann das Ganze auch nochmal runterbrechen, wenn man möchte. Und einfach die Programmiersprache, mit der man selber arbeitet, vorstellen. Hauptsache sie ist objektorientiert. Beziehungsweise, man kann damit objektorientiert programmieren. Und versteht das. 0331 77 97 1 0. Das ist die Telefonnummer. Danke, der Tobias.
Wünsche einen schönen Tag noch.
Der Sandro.
Es ist eigentlich langsam Zeit für die besondere Musik, oder? Es ist Nachmitternacht.
Die besondere Musik.
Ja, was haben wir denn hier noch an besonderem Musik? Schauen wir mal.
Das ist schön. Die Arschlochwelt ist doch immer am längeren Hebel.
Gerade das macht sie doch dazu.
Sitzt immer am kürzeren Ast.
Madonna, immer wieder für schöne Musikgut, weil sie auch Musik macht, nicht?
Ich wollte ja ein bisschen auf die Arschdachwelt hinweisen, aber da hab ich mich leider verklickt.
Das spielen wir zum Schluss nochmal.
Ja, das holen wir nochmal. Wir haben ja noch ein paar andere lustige Sachen.
Aber jetzt haben wir erstmal noch ein Hörer.
Wir haben noch jemand am Telefon. Ihr hört den Chaosradio Blue Moon, um diejenigen, die jetzt hier wild einsteigen, nochmal daran erinnern, dass das auf Fritz jetzt am Start ist. Und es geht um objektorientiertes Programmieren, für den Fall, dass ihr gar nicht wisst, was das ist. Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde und innerhalb dieser 35 Minuten wird der Groschen fallen. Das sei geschworen. Am Telefon ist der Felix, namens Felix.
Ich komme eher aus der grafischen Richtung und habe mit Programmierungen erst mal nicht so viel zu tun gehabt.
Ich habe jetzt im Prinzip nur mit Skriptsprachen zu tun gehabt.
Die kamen jetzt sehr schlecht weg den ganzen Abend. Aber da tut sich ja auch viel in Richtung objektorientierte Programmierungen.
Also wenigstens für meinen Einsteigereindruck, sage ich mal.
Also ich habe mit Lingo und Action Skript von Flash zu tun. Und sowohl die Buchtitel als auch Tutorials im Netz reden immer wieder von objektorientierter Programmierweise oder Ansätzen in diesen Skriptsprachen.
Ja, das ist, also wir wollten nicht so verstanden wissen, dass wir generell Skriptsprachen als etwas Schlechteres darstellen. Das ist nicht der Punkt.
Nämlich ihr, der Vorredner vor allen Dingen.
Also ich denke er bezog sich vor allen Dingen auf so Sachen wie Shell-Programmierung oder Perl-Programmierung. Also Shell ist besonders widerwärtig und Perl ist zwar sehr mächtig, aber auch sehr kryptisch. Also wenn man das einmal hingeschrieben hat, hat man hinterher Mühe, das wieder lesen zu können. Und ich hab jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel Lingoerfahrung. Ich hab da sozusagen mal einen kurzen Blick auf Sourcen geworfen und das sah für mich eigentlich alles relativ anständig und verständlich aus.
Objektorientierte Konzepte findet man halt mittlerweile überall. So, es gibt Programmiersprachen, die in ihrer ureigenen Intention gedacht sind, um das objektorientierende Programmieren so einfach wie möglich zu machen. Und Sprachen wie Lingo kommen, sagen wir mal, eher aus dem Bedarf multimedial-interaktiver Anwendungen und haben vor allem das Konzept der Events und das Handling von Events verinnerlicht. Und das ist aber auch so fern der objektorientierten Abstraktion auch nicht.
Es ist ja auch ein gewisser Unterschied, ob ich jetzt eine generelle Programmiersprache hab, so wie Perlin, der ich kurz meine CGI-Bins runterhack, oder ob ich einfach jetzt eine Programmforme hab, wie zum Beispiel Director und da einfach was steuern will, was skripten will, dann ist ja eine Skrittsprache unvermeidlich, das geht gar nicht. Anders hat er oft ein Programm und ich will dem dynamisch was sagen, ist es eigentlich immer eine Skrittsprache.
Ich meine, wo hört das dann auf?
Es gibt da keinen Unterschied. Du bist ein typisches Beispiel für den Irrglauben, sie würden Skripte schreiben, aber nicht programmieren. Skripte schreiben ist programmieren, da besteht kein Unterschied und der ist dann nur virtuell, damit Leute nicht so erschrecken, wenn sie anfangen Skripte zu schreiben.
Da hab ich mich vielleicht falsch ausgedrückt. Also, dass ich programmiere in dem Sinne, ist mir schon bewusst.
Nur wo fängt die Objektorientierung an?
Denn im Prinzip ist ja das ganze Konzept, sag ich mal, von Flash zum Beispiel ein einziges Objektorientiererei sozusagen.
Also, die Objektorientierung fängt im Wesentlichen in deinem Kopf an. Die einzige interessante Frage ist, inwieweit ich die Sprache dabei unterstütze, indem sie dir Mechanismen bietet, die objektorientierte Abstraktion in deinem Kopf auch tatsächlich in etwas, was auf dem Bildschirm steht, umzusetzen. Und die Features können viele Ausprägungen haben. Und in dem Sinne ist das natürlich schon objektorientiert.
Aber so genau, jetzt zum Beispiel für Flash oder für Directors Lingo, wisst ihr nicht wirklich, wie gut die, sag ich mal, Objektorientierung unterstützen?
Also ich kenn die Sprachfeatures jetzt nicht konkret. Also da hat man ja auch eigentlich wenig Alternative, weil keine anderen Sprachen eingebaut sind im Direktor.
Naja, gerade im Internetbereich kann man ja dann wieder gucken, ob man dann sozusagen mit klassischen oder nur Programmierern zusammenarbeitet und die eben irgendwas auf Serverbasis machen, was man dann nur noch irgendwie importieren muss.
Aber meine Frage an der Stelle ist, inwiefern kann man sowas im Internet überhaupt gebrauchen? Also bei Objektorientierung ja, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, innerhalb der letzten zweieinhalb Stunden, darauf hin abzielt, dass man eine ganze Menge mehr zu tun hat, als dieses eine Ding runterzuschreiben und deswegen Objekte macht, die man mehrfach benutzen kann. Fürs Web, wenn ich da eine Grafik hinbaue, weil du gesagt hast, du arbeitest grafikorientiert, brauche ich doch meistens nur eine Variante dieses Dings.
Man braucht das immer und überall. Man will eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts nicht irgendwie abstrakt hinschreiben. Also auch gerade um eben etwas mal eben schnell zu machen. Gerade sowas eigentlich super Komplexes, wie ich male einen Kreis. Das ist ja irgendwie ein vergleichsweise aufwändiger Algorithmus, um zu bestimmen, wo kommt in den nächsten Punkt hin und dann vielleicht noch mit Anti-Aliasing und bunten Farben. Deswegen möchte man da halt schon es bequem haben. Und umso mehr man wiederverwenden kann und umso abstrakter man es formulieren kann, umso besser ist es für mich.
Das heißt, es lohnt sich immer?
Es lohnt sich immer.
Ja, Felix, schön, dass du da eine Lanze gebrochen hast.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
Die Uhrzeit 0 Uhr 29.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Deswegen will genau zu diesem kommen. Das Wetter nachts fällt vereinzelt so ein bisschen Regen. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 8 bis 5 Grad zurück. Am Tag erzieht das Wetter von West nach Ost. Kleines Regengebiet kommt dadurch die Region. Und dabei sind vereinzelt Gewitter und Sturmböen möglich, die die Autos aber am Platz stehen lassen. Die Temperaturen liegen bei 9 bis 11 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Kerstin Topp.
Der Bundestag hat am Abend der Einfuhr embryonaler Stammzellen unter strengen Auflagen zugestimmt. Während die Kirchen sich enttäuscht zeigten, begrüßten Forscher den Parlamentsbeschluss. In der afghanischen Provinz Paktia haben sich rivalisierende Truppen Gefechte geliefert. Dabei soll es Tote und Verletzte gegeben haben. Auslöser für die Kämpfe war offenbar ein Streit um den Gouverneursposten der Provinz. Indien hat erneut eine Rakete getestet. Wie das Verteidigungsministerium in Neu-Delhi mitteilte, wurde an der Südwestküste eine Flugabwehrrakete gezündet. Erst am Freitag hatte Indien eine Rakete getestet, die auch mit einem Atomsprengkopf bestückt werden kann. Brandenburg will mit einem neuen Arbeitsmarktmodell mehr Jobs für ausgebildete Jugendliche schaffen. Dabei sollen sich zwei Absolventen eine Stelle teilen. Das Arbeitsamt wird den Lohn jeweils auf 80 Prozent aufstocken. Und zum Sport im Viertelfinale um den DFB-Pokal gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Hertha BSC 1. FC Köln 1 zu 2 nach Verlängerung. Bayer Leverkusen 1860 München 3 zu 0. Schalke 04 Rot-Weiß Oberhausen 2 zu 0. Die Partie Kaisers Lautern gegen Bayern München endete 3 zu 5 im Elfmeterschießen. Zuvor stand es 0 zu 0 nach Verlängerung. Und in der Basketball-Euroleague verlor der deutsche Meister Albert Berlin am Abend beim polnischen Titelträger Slask Breslau mit 66 zu 71. Derzeit liegen uns keine Verkehrsmeldung vor.
Das nächste Konzert. Ascha.
Sonntag, 3.
März, Arena Berlin.
Das Star-Aufgebot 2002.
Mehr Infos, musst du, musst du klicken, klicken.
www.fritz.de Ascha, Sascha, fettes Brot, Mary J. Blind, die toten hohe Kylie Minow.
Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen.
Ein System kann sie nicht selbst beseitigen.
Ein System kann sie nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sie nicht selbst beseitigen.
Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen. Ein System kann sich nicht selbst beseitigen.
Wir können auch Two-Step, so könnte man das formulieren, musikalisierenderweise. Das Chaosradio ist am Start und zwar noch 25 Minuten genau. Heute Abend geht es ums Programmieren bzw. genauer oder sozusagen die Klasse ausgenutzt und schon eine Instanz definiert um Objektorientiertes Programmieren. Wer das jetzt nicht mehr verstanden hat, der, was hat es nicht gelernt, der kennt ja den Spruch. Genau, so ungefähr. Leider Gottes, aber es ist nicht so die einfachste Geschichte der Welt. Also ich werde es wahrscheinlich so im Ansatz begriffen haben, wenn ich heute Abend fertig bin. Ansonsten im Studio vom Chaos Computer Club der Mitsch, der Andreas und der Tim. Mein Name ist Malotki und am Telefon ist der Sven namens Sven. Mit einer Frage im Gepäck.
Ja, auch, auch. Also es ist jetzt etwas Konkreteres zum Überladen von Operatoren im Python, weil irgendwie komme ich damit nicht so ganz klar. Aber erstmal generell, Objektorientiertes Programmieren ist nicht schwer. Ich kann es auch nochmal sagen. Man lernt es innerhalb eines Nachmittags. Am Endeffekt ist es nur eine andere Syntax. Der Rest ergibt sich dann von ganz alleine. Wenn es auf einmal Krieg macht, man denkt, ah, das habe ich jetzt also getan. Das war jetzt nochmal das Statement.
Und du machst das mit Python?
Ja, und zwar überladen von Operatoren. Das Problem ist ja, in Python gibt es ja nicht wirklich. Jedenfalls habe ich es noch nicht wirklich gemerkt, die Unterscheidung zwischen Objekten. Vor allem, wenn man sie definiert. Man sagt nicht, dieses Ding ist jetzt ein Integer oder sonst was. Es ist einfach da. Und man kann irgendwie über einen Kommando namens type rausfinden, was es denn nun im Endeffekt wirklich ist.
Das ist eine dynamisch geteupte Pyramidsprache.
Ja. Ja, und jetzt ist die Frage natürlich, da ich ja alles durchschleifen kann, theoretisch durch einen Constructor, durch eine Argumentenkette, wie finde ich denn im Endeffekt wieder raus, was es war? Weil Python schmeißt nur Exceptions, wenn ich das versuche. Also irgendwie habe ich das noch nicht ganz geschaut.
Es ehrt mich, dass du mir auch diese Frage stellst, aber ich würde dir nicht wirklich eine Antwort geben können. Ich gebe das einfach mal weiter an die Herren.
Ja, Python, ich habe mal ein bisschen Python gemacht, aber mit dem Überladen von Operatoren habe ich mich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht beschäftigt. Was genau probierst du denn zu tun?
Ja, so jetzt müsste ich wieder mal in mein Source Code ran. Es war irgendwas mit einer Konsole, die ich versucht habe zu bauen. Ein Python, also einfach Eingabe und das gleich wieder ausgeben. Ich entschuldige mich fürs Knacken, besser gesagt die Telekom entschuldigt sich. Jetzt müsste ich natürlich mal das jetzt lesen können. So und zwar ich hatte mir gemacht ein schönes Objekt, eine schöne Klasse und wollte da was reingeben. Über einen Operator mit drei Argumenten. Und ich wollte eigentlich nur ein anderes Objekt durchschleißen und dieses dann kontrollieren, ob es auch wirklich da angekommen ist. Also es hat was mit Überladen von Operatoren zu tun, jetzt habe ich es.
Überladen von Operatoren, also warum willst du dafür einen Operator überladen?
Es ging darum, ein Vektor zu implementieren und das sieht halt hübscher aus, wenn man das so tut.
Bist du dir sicher, dass das sinnvoll ist?
Gibt es keine Iteratoren in Python? Gibt es keine Iteratoren in Python?
Also ein Vektor im Sinne von einem Array oder als mathematischer Vektor?
Als mathematischer.
Also so A plus B ist quasi so, dass du A plus B schreiben kannst oder A minus B.
In dem Fall ist das sogar erlaubt. Also es gibt Leute, die neigen dazu nur, weil es Operator-Overloading in ihrer Programmiersprache gibt, das zu allen möglichen Zwecken zu verwenden. Also manchmal sieht man es noch ein. Also wenn man einen Plus nimmt, um zwei Strings hintereinander zu hängen. Aber manchmal auch nicht mehr. Also wenn dann irgendwelche Leute mit dem Shift-Left-Operator was ausgeben, wie in C++, das ist dann nur noch widerlich. Aber in dem Fall zwei Vektoren zu addieren, da ist das genau der Anwendungsfall. Weil das Plus, was man da hinschreibt, genau das Plus ist, was jeder erwartet. Da werden zwei mathematische Objekte addiert.